I get the painful ones, bro. Yeah. What's
that? What's that like the time, size,
tissue, deep tissue. Should I lower
this? Whatever you want. No, whatever.
Whatever feels comfortable for you.
But it's pretty good at picking up
your voice. You just want to know,
you don't want to have it that low.
You definitely want to have it in front
of your face. Okay. It's like a radio one.
It's not a stage one.
So like it's a sideways Mike.
If you see it like the Mike is in. Oh
yeah, I just go. This is how I do it.
I have this like right in
front of my face. Okay.
Plus people don't get to see as much
of my face. It makes me, me staring.
I like it when I used to sit there
used to hide behind it. Like, like hey,
I'm half robot. Half man. All right,
let's do this. Three, two, one
popping [inaudible] when we drink we do
[inaudible] three six [inaudible] six
six [inaudible] me now wait,
wait.
Give me that Christmas Day ladies
love my staff table cabled.
Wow.
Been that drought that can meet two more
bottles. Cause you know we don't say
drinking.
I,
I'm like the truck.
Please drink
like three six,
six g,
g,
G.
I think the g six is a jet. Okay. You
think as a jet or think so. All right.
I'm a fucking retard. I
always think apple like, oh,
they got any make g six
these are way above the game.
They sound like they're falling. They
sound like they're born, right? Yeah.
They've got a bunch of
girls that are sober,
but they're pretending to be drunk so
they can fuck. Yeah. Okay. That ball,
that starts,
that's when you're out of control.
When people are pretending they need an
excuse to fuck you. Yes. All right. Yes.
That's what's going on. Speaking with
the excuse. Excuses the fuck you.
Michelle's sponsored by the flashlight.
Ladies and gentlemen, last slide.
If you go to Joe rogan.net
and you click on the link,
it'll take you to the fleshlight
website and they give you 15% off.
What's a flashlight? A flashlight is,
this one is an alien version. By the way.
Our guest is little Esther and Esther
is a very funny standup comedian here in
Los Angeles, California. And uh,
she's our first female guest ever,
ladies and gentlemen. So how about a round
of applause? 50th episode? Yeah. Also,
this is our 50th episode and we, we, you
know, we just never found a girl worthy.
But you're here, you're
here. They're all worthy.
They just don't want to come
over. And, and not only that,
it's my house so I can't bring porn
stars over embers will usually do have
boards doors on, you know, well,
you know, you can do all you want.
It's just the issue is I have little
children that are girls want them being
really good friends with the porn star
and said, I want to do it in Maryland.
Does, you know she's obsessed with porn
star. She actually bought off of Ebay,
Jenna Jamison socks or something
like that. Sweater off of Ebay. Wow.
Did,
did it smell like jizz fairy
princess fairy princesses.
It was cute. She's a nice
person. I bet you could meet her.
If you ever went to the fcs
obsession with her.
What is the obsession like she does so
many things that I would not do and it's
just cool and exciting and she's pretty,
and she wrote a book that was good.
You actually liked her book? I loved
her book. I've read it like three times.
I bought it in high school and I used
to have to put like a fake cover over it
so I could read it in high school. No one
know what I was reading. Whoa. Yeah. Um,
so was that like, like, like
inspiring to you or not?
I mean,
yeah.
When you say that she does like a lot
of things that you wouldn't do. Yeah.
Like she's important star. Um, and
she's just so different from me.
Like I'm like a little,
thank you Brian.
Brian just put a floppy dick and asters
lap that's from the ones they made them.
It's sort of a proof of concept device.
Like they didn't make it so that anyone
can use it obviously because it's too
soft and it wouldn't really be functional
unless you just into disappointment.
But, uh, they just wanted to show that
they could get this deck. It's very,
it's disturbing. You know, a lot of
it's circumcise too. Yeah, it's soft.
It's kind of crazy that the norm
is to cut a chunk of your dick off.
That's the norm.
If someone said this to me,
I don't remember who it was they're
talking about if he had a boy,
would you circumcise it? I
said, no. I said, it's, I think
it's ridiculous. I go, what?
You want to chop a piece
of skin off someone's Dick?
And it makes it less sensitive and
the whole deal. And he goes, yeah,
but it looks better.
That's what I saying.
It does look better, but I don't. Does
it really? No, really? I think so.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't get
it. Have you had both? No, I haven't. Oh,
have you seen the other one
in person? No, not in person.
I think when it's soft, yeah.
It looks very animal like, yeah.
When it's soft, it's like the skins
over it. It's like an elephant Dick.
It's just like, eh. I
never seen it soft. I whoa,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Get a rock hard. And while that's you,
you're just very sexy, circumcised men
around you. They can't help themselves.
It's um, it's a terrible thing. You're
chopping a Jew. I mean, people, Ooh,
it's hard gene. You know these
people in Africa, it's ridiculous.
It's not a hygiene issue.
I'm sort of against it because it's
to look tissue you sort of against it.
Yeah, because like, it's like
you said, it's cutting skin off.
That seems just wrong. It's not like
a, it's helps anything. You know?
It's not like he cut skin off and then
you could see behind your back like,
oh no god, I bought back there,
but this is an extra piece of skin.
Let's get rid of that skin. Dude, there's
an eyeball back here. This is crazy.
You don't believe in like having an
umbilical cord still like as grownup.
That's stupid. What? Well,
I mean, and you're like,
don't want to modify the body how it is,
you know,
that's not a good analogy at all. Terrible
knows you. That's all he ever does.
Dry Low fucking stuff in the conversation.
There's tracks put some silly nonsense,
but it's funny to get their haircut.
She doesn't, she gets angry and mad.
No, I just, I appreciate a good analogy.
So when a bad one is presented to me,
explain a good one.
Then that's also like that
like piercing your ears.
You're modifying your a little teeny piece
of your body, your skin Stenek thing.
Well, so is the Dick thing?
Yeah. What else does it for you?
The issue is that it changes
the functionality of the penis.
You no longer like when the
four skin is over your penis,
your penis is much more
sensitive because it's protected.
Now your penis is all like calloused
and like tired out role and against your
underwear and it's rubbing
against your leg. It's like, it's,
the tip part is really supposed to be
protected by skin so that it makes it even
more sensitive.
So you'd have way more problems
with premature ejaculation
apparently because it
will just feel better. It was as good as
it feels now. It feel even crazy better.
You know, people who go to wounded to
feel better, but that's ridiculous.
Why would I want more sensitivity?
You know,
we'd like to talk about penises and
show it's good. I forgot to warn you.
I get to talk about
penises. So, yeah, right.
All my stand up is very clean. So
it was Jenna Jamison, the only, um,
you're not though. You're dirty, right?
Yes, you are clean. Are you kidding?
You're not dirty as in
like fuck, fuck, fuck.
But you're a dirty as in like
the subjects you bring up.
Abortion jokes are not really insults.
I like to install the abortion insult.
I like to insult hot women because
some of them are mean to me.
So. So you insult them with
abortion jokes? No. Well, okay.
Like people say that blondes
have more fun. That's fine.
I've never had to have an abortion.
So that's, that's the joke.
It is kind of a tricky thing.
If you really break it down as to what
it is. I mean you're, you, it's alive.
You know, it's, it's, it's inside your
body. You're hosting it and you know,
you get to terminate that
because it's inside your body.
You get to pull the trigger.
But whoa,
that's a crazy gray area because
it comes out, it becomes a person.
It's very strange. I mean I understand
why people would do it. I do as well,
honestly.
Cause I wouldn't,
I have nightmares about having children
and it's not happening, but it's,
I don't know,
just,
it's just basically saying that
one women are whores and I don't
particularly blondes. But Jenna
Jamison is a huge support. Like your,
your big idol. Well she
is, but I like, it's,
I'm really just insulting
like the blonde, the, it's
not all the specific ones.
The ones that like are mean to me and
like picked on me in high school. Um,
what did they used to do here?
Like throw like bloody tampons at you
when you walk down the hall and stuff. No,
I just did a pilot audition
where that happened to me. Okay.
Every audition I've ever been on,
the breakdowns are traumatizing cause I'm
listed as unattractive and like Chubby.
But anyway,
yeah. So Michael, Charles, what these
boots, before you go anywhere with this,
obviously something happened.
So tell us what,
what these guys did to you that makes
you want to bring them up specifically?
Um,
nothing really.
I just think that sometimes like you go
out and you see like the hot chicks that
like wear mini skirts and
tons of makeup and like I'm,
when I'm ever in their vicinity,
like I'm like this like in jeans and a
tee shirt and sneakers and I feel like
they like look at me
and think I'm retarded.
Okay.
But are they actually doing anything
to you or are they just looking hot and
you're getting Yang?
Um, they're just looking hot and
I get angry. Whoa. No weird. No,
they're mean to me. They're mean
to you. Okay, let's go there. Um,
do they mean to you? Okay,
well one I used to go to,
like I would go to movies and people
would follow me into the movie theater and
like yell things at me. Like they
were meeting, like I was picked on,
like what you face stinky farts.
Like Esther, the molester,
he molested girls that you knew. Um, yeah,
I think people just picked on me because
I like was a nerd. Is that normal?
Yes. That's normal. Yeah. Yeah, but it's
just those kinds that you grew up with.
It's really all blocked me.
I believe it.
I love how I have a blog that's called
Esther with hot chicks.com and I just
take pictures with hot people and
talk about them. Really? Yeah.
One of the pictures is me and
Brittany Murphy, his grave site.
It was great. It's just the pitcher
for, and there's like this like this,
like square of flowers on the ground
and she's just sitting there like, yeah,
I like it. I love it. Don't get
me wrong. I love attractive women.
Like I'm obsessed with them to the
point of like, I could be a lesbian,
but there's someone's that I just,
they get me mad and I don't like them,
so I want to say mean things about them.
Like if they, it basically this started,
we can also too, because I get heckled
a lot by hot chicks and they're like,
you're a Dork. And like I just
come back at them like, no,
you're a disgusting,
filthy whore and no one likes you and
I'm not gonna listen to you because I'm
not interested in having sex with you.
Wow. So they're, they're, they're
tricks don't work on you there.
I'm not a psychologist.
I might think you have an issue.
I don't have an issue. Might be
an issue here. It seems like,
it certainly seems like it's an
issue. What's the issue? Well,
I mean you've got an anger towards a
very specific group of the part of the
population. Girls that are
attractive. No, I don't. I like them.
We did them with clients with
assholes. Is that wrong? But yeah,
because you made it attractive.
Like they're attractive and their cons.
So it's really like what it
is is like being attractive.
They have this extra gift that you wish
you had. Like they're, they're hotter,
they're in the group. And then the current
part is like, well, they're just cuts,
plea. You've thrown it all together.
Just the fact that they're attractive,
it's really, doesn't mean
anything. They're just assholes.
If they're hot and they're
nice, they're great. I,
but I think that Alpha hot woman is mean.
It's like the biggest disservice to the
world because you're not representing
duty. But yeah, but, but
you see what I'm saying?
Like you don't necessarily have to lump
in hot along with cont just so happens
that they're hot, but the real issue, is
that correct? Yeah. And that's your enemy.
It's the clients.
It's not hot girls.
Sometimes people like to see
the nerdy Jew girl attack.
They'd like to know that I'm
attacking the hot women. Right, right.
But if you do it for no reason,
it's one thing as you're attacking
me for no reason. Absolutely. Okay.
But it seems like you have a reason
that maybe they might not be involved in
personally, we might be a
reason. It's like you're,
you're going back to four years ago.
They're in the moment and they're like,
what the fuck is this chick screaming
at me for just cause I'm hot? No,
cause they're conti. They're just
[inaudible] know what I'm saying.
It's like what the, the
hot part is irrelevant. It
doesn't mean anything. Well,
it just makes it worse because not
only are they acting a certain way,
they're getting treated a
certain way cause they're hot.
Ultimate enemy to a girl probably is
a hot chick. That is also a kind of,
so really the problem was weak dudes that
are willing to treat hot chicks and in
a superior way. Right. There's
through really problem. Of
course you understand it.
They're like hot chicks
are like super celebrities.
Literally if I go into like
a really pretty girl, like
wearing like a hot outfit,
I just look at her like she's a
princess and like want to talk to her.
If she's nice then so you have
this love hate thing going on.
Very strong and I just don't know yet.
Have you made out withdrawals and stuff?
Um,
yes.
My Freshman Year of high school I kind
of see that fluff site real quick video
tape with two other girls
in my high school though of
us making out and touching
each other's boobs and it
made us very popular. Wow.
So you guys released it
online or have it? Uh, I do.
I don't know how to play it cause
it's not like an old, totally,
you just need the cables.
Brian knows how to get it online.
But it's also illegal because I
was 13. No, no, no. We can put cat,
the cat faces on the heads.
They'll never know. You know,
that's a tricky thing man.
You can't really, if they
could prove that she was 15,
you know how dangerous that is.
Girls are getting arrested.
High school girls are getting arrested
because they send boys pictures of their
Posey and that's child
pornography. So this woman, yeah,
and I mean it's sexting. That's
what everyone's calling it. Sexting.
But the courts are calling
the child pornography. Right.
It's a cute name to use.
So it doesn't sound like they're sending
child pornography. Yeah. This one girl,
um,
she's 15 years old and they arrested her
for child pornography because she sent
some boys pictures of her pussy and then
he sent them to everybody and she was
obviously the source. So, and they all
got, everyone was in trouble and so they,
they wound up like taking it to court
and they moved it. They changed the,
the charge to possession of
criminal tools. Oh my God.
So instead of child pornography,
possession of criminal
tools, because her phone,
her cell phone was a tool for crime cause
she took a picture of her pussy with
her cell phone. Like man,
we need some new laws.
Like we need some new laws to catch
up with 2010 and this technology,
because we're using like fucking smoke
signals and you know, the, the, the,
you know, the, the, the Pony Express.
I mean we're using that kind of technology
to deal with kids. You know, you,
if we're in an area where kids have
phones and the phones have cameras,
they're going to take pictures of their
assholes. They just get to do everything.
They're going to take pictures of
everything they can. They're kids.
They're curious. They're more likely to
do if they know they're not supposed to.
They don't have any willpower.
They don't know that things are gross
or embarrassing or shocking or, yeah,
they make terrible choices. We need
some laws, man. They need some new laws.
He's still film yourself like a lot nick,
by yourself.
Do you ever want to be a porn star?
No.
I think when I was younger I was like
that a little bit and then I sort of went
through like a transition of
liking stand up comedy so,
well, how'd you get into San
Diego? Porn lays just the message.
They go together a lot,
like of like same Tripoli's Nice.
Show it the porn mixed with comedy.
It just seems like like salt and pepper.
It just seems like they're supposed to go
together for some take two go together.
Well,
because it's like you can't take yourself
too seriously with either one of them.
Right. You know, and you're looked down
upon by a lot of people to, you know,
like mentally disturbed
to do both. Yeah. Yeah.
The reason why you get into all of them
is there's a deficit. There is always a,
an unusual need for attention is either
touched by your mother or a hit by your
father. What's, and it
doesn't necessarily,
I've actually met comics that have good
families. They're just, they're funny.
Yeah.
Porn stars are having,
I've never met a porn star that
doesn't come from some chaos. Right.
Have you ever seen that?
What's that one porn star that's a
dad is like the porn star manager. Uh,
have you seen that? It was like on
that HBO show. Uh, I did see that.
I don't remember her name. I feel like
it's sunny lane. No. Is it sunny lane?
Maybe funny lane is that,
it might be Google that shit real quick.
But it was the most disturbing
thing if you haven't seen it.
She was on the show with her parents
who manage her porn career and they were
talking about terrific.
It is, it's so awesome.
Like she won the number one video
of the year. That's our daughter.
They're all like all excited and shit.
It was like, it was so twisted and weird.
And then she wound up working as a whore
and a brothel and the dad was talking
about the brothel. Like wow. They give
up, they feed them, they give them food.
I saw that it was clean.
Like whoa,
truckers can just come in there
and fuck your little baby's mouth.
And that's not weird to you.
All they have to do is come up with
150 bucks or whatever it costs.
They can fuck your baby's mouth and you're
happy about it. Yeah. Wildly feeder.
They feed it.
They feed
sick Jack all day. Yeah.
It was a very disturbing,
but I think any kid that comes from
that background, you know, you're just,
you know, that's your parents
probably your foot, your
shit's going to fall. This.
Yeah.
Any chick that comes from that
background is just fuck man.
What chance do you have? I mean, you
know, that's the one thing that I see.
So clearly having babies,
you see how you behave with them and how,
you know you can influence their
behavior and calm them down and put them,
get them to think about things like
explain things to them. You know,
we don't do this because if we do this
then it's going to hurt other people's
feelings. And then you
have them repeat it. Yeah,
we're going to hurt other people's
feelings. So we don't want to do that.
And she'll stop herself and
say things like that to me.
So it's like her mind is off in the
right direction. But if you're, if that,
if that's your mom or you know, if that's
your dad, you're gonna act one way.
But if your dad is like
you stupid fucking content,
you're just like your mother and then also
your and your two and you're like, oh,
I don't think that that's not happening.
I mean people are out there.
There's a story I read. It
was a heartbreaking story.
A guy who is with his, uh,
his girlfriend's baby and it wasn't
his baby. The baby was two years old.
He beat it to death two years old.
So I don't think that,
I mean 90,
I think in my opinion,
99% of all the problems that we have
in our society is the way people are
raised. 99%. Totally
agree. People raising,
get the fuck Outta here with this. Who is
calling me during the podcast? How rude.
One robot voice. My mom, she heard I
was talking about her cause from Dhl.
Joe Has not paying attention to the
positives. I can fuck what the fuck.
Cock soccer,
I'm calling put me online.
You don't got the technology
Brian and get that shit together.
Come on Cock sucker. I want to be
able to call in. I got questions. Um,
99% in my opinion.
I mean that's a fake number.
I just pulled it out
of my ass as a a good,
a good chunk of the reason we're fucked.
It's because the way people raise kids,
you know,
no one is raising kids to,
to look at the entire human race as one
giant organism and just to be as cool as
possible and make as many
positive connections as possible.
We're all raising kids to fucking go out
there and compete and go kick ass and
be the best to make money and get
ahead and then what Di, you know,
fuck we're,
we're messing it all up or we're not
enjoying the time here and now we have,
we have all this fucking
cool shit going on in,
in this country and everybody's
pissed off about the future.
It was sunny lane by the way,
that they like show her parents packet.
They show parents, her
parents packing, uh,
for her like putting clothes inside thing,
her suitcase,
there's your toothbrush
and here's your ass cream.
I watched one of reports after
that and I felt so dirty.
I felt like I shouldn't
have been watching it.
Like I was like her counselor or something
like that and I was watching her porn,
you know.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I felt like I knew she
was fucked up then. You know,
I knew there was just a lot, a lot of
issues. And then I watched this video and
I'm like yeah what am I doing my watching
her suck someone's Dick for gross as
so die and or yeah,
yeah you said d the amp varied rap band
for for those who don't know it's from
South Africa. I think though the American
way of saying it. Cause even Jim Kim,
Jimmy Kimmel said die Antwoord
or something like that.
He didn't say it like all
weird and I think this is,
there's like an American way to say it
and maybe he just fucked up cause they
provide, I pre, pre told don and then
he went and checked on it and yeah.
And they all said at the same way.
Hmm.
Guy From South Africa told me
was Deann Vert Danford whose DNV?
[inaudible] well let's,
let's listen to Ninja say it.
Put on that Ziff side video and listened
to him. So, all right. Have you,
are you familiar with them? Asked her.
Um, I've heard a little bit. I'm obsessed.
I'm obsessed with them because they're so,
it's a legitimate,
it's like in this world of like, I mean,
not zen, anything wrong with lady Gaga.
I think lady Gaga was very talented.
I really do. I know I like her.
I think she's talented. She's
got a great voice. She's hard.
She's got a killer body and she, you know,
she's out there making noise. I mean,
for, for whatever reason, but it's not
working on me. You know what I'm saying?
It's like, I see what you're doing.
I see that you're working at,
and I appreciate the mastery of,
you know,
working in controlling the media and
having all these people on your side and
lady Gaga doesn't work for you.
You don't like that.
So she's not saying shit to me.
It's all just,
you're singing songs and you're wearing
meat on your tits. And it's like, okay,
it's not legit to me. Listen, it's
not, what I'm saying is it's not,
it's not someone who is being,
it's not genuine to me,
these feeble, I like what they're doing
is like this fucking, first of all,
it's ugly. They look dirty.
They have fucked up hair.
This guys get the shittiest tattoos ever.
You know, he knows he's ugly as fuck.
You know what I mean? And he's ugly too.
That she's hot. She's hot, she's hot,
she's hot, but she has like
sort of an ugly face dude.
The girl you mean Lady
Gaga? Oh, Lady Gaga. Oh,
I thought you were talking about
Uilani. Oh No, I want to see her though.
I heard you guys saying that
she was, she's Hoxie. Yeah,
Lady Gaga has got a Funky mug.
But you know what,
that's why she's working so
hard. Yeah, she was hot as fuck.
She'd be like those kinds of the
club with no ambition. Exactly right.
That's why you have to be a little bit,
I appreciate it. I appreciate Lady Gaga.
Don't get me wrong. I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with her.
I mean it's not my kind of music. I,
there's a couple of songs that I enjoy,
but it's not, it's boring to me that
mum poker foods like just hocked deck.
This is, this is the real
shit. This is uh, this is um,
what's his name? Ninja that high
tech or whatever his name is.
Well just hit play.
This is DJ hoc deck that up the
mother fucking beat box dog.
I love the South African accent
to bring that next level shit.
That's what I'm talking about.
Checking out.
Don't be [inaudible] Yo yo Yo pick up the,
I've got Bob, the name of Jay does
a mug insulating your brain locked
the static step Gulf,
the Three d graphics
scoping throwed off.
Strobing Mondo will sweat streaming.
Flash dreaming does feeling hot and deep
meanings break. When I say things like,
this chick in a dish today,
can I touch you for the end?
Where's it saying in it? It's in the
video. Are you playing the video?
Are you playing the,
Oh, okay, well do you don't have
it says the advert and they says,
what does that is the answer. Yeah. And
then he goes to answer to why audios,
whatever.
Actually I like lady Gaga Music.
I liked that song operator where she's
like telephone, where like, you know,
like it starts scrambling up in the song.
Just like if you were talking on his
cell phone. Yeah. Yeah. I like that.
I think that's a good song.
Don't get me wrong.
I think she's creative music too
though. Yeah. I like dirty people.
I like dirty people. I like people would
fucking dirt under their fingernails,
stinky breath and good stories.
But when I first met her,
she didn't wear deodorant. It had
to talk her into wearing, oh my God.
Are we being open about our situation
here on the show as being friends?
You guys be in pals making video
for friends and you, um, you,
you just smelled her and you're like,
hey, this has got to change. Right.
You used to be like that too though.
Like you didn't like wearing
deodorant at one point. Still don't.
I like on like a monkey.
I think that if a man likes the way my
underarm smell, then we're a good match.
Really.
He can deal with a lot of other things
like a genetic or like whatever it is.
Yeah.
You don't want to deal with some weak
dues pushed off by a little under set.
I think it's cute. I like that
fragile. That's a great conversation.
But when you're trying to
be a struggling actress,
and then she was on the Jimmy
Kimmel show as her brother,
no sister as her sister and her part
was Jimmy Kimmel's head right underneath
her armpit. And can you imagine it
was stinking? No, she was probably,
well maybe it's just me.
Cam, we'll call you back.
Wash yourself before you went on.
Well, I got the call to do that show.
Like literally I had 30 minutes to get
there. So No. So when you got there,
did you smell your underarms and give a
little check? I'm pretty sure I was fine.
You're pretty sure no one ever
thinks they stink though. Yeah,
but mentioned Jimmy Kimmel's nose right
in her arm pit for like how long did it
take the film? That shit.
Yeah, he's probably going to
think, oh this girl stinks.
So you have to have a perfect stinky girl.
Yeah,
you have to be at like a professional.
You're a right.
So when you, when people talk vegans,
they'll automatically think stinky feet
close. Literally just, I dunno,
I like it because I think dairy is bad
for you and that makes me feel sick.
That's Diaz. Jose, we've
got a fucking problem.
But soy milk actually tastes pretty good.
Like soy milk lattes.
That motherfucker just put
your phone off the hook. Yeah, I can't,
it's not like it's in the
other room and just have the,
he said he's one of those add guys
that'll keep calling it and then when you
answer he'll get angry at you.
What the fuck? Cock sucker.
I called you five fucking
times. Like, can I take a nap?
Is it okay if I take a nap? I called
you cocksucker you don't call me back.
Don't call me back. What the
fuck's going on? Funny. I'm sorry.
We were talking about um,
hippies and so you became [inaudible].
I'm sorry you're not a,
you're not a hit,
but you're vegan because
dairy is bad for you.
You just want to do it for health reasons.
For health reasons basically. Yeah,
I thought about doing that. Yeah,
it's good. I feel better and I like,
it's easy though in Los Angeles to do
it because there's so many restaurants
that have vegan like cake and
you know, stuff like that. Cook.
That's what you need. Cake. Well,
I'm like really concerned about animals,
but I don't want to make sure
that this cake cake available,
then I can do it. Right. Well,
when you don't smoke or drink,
there's very few things you have
in life. Right, right, right.
Why don't you try drinking?
They'll mellowly like, like wine.
I know a lot of people enjoy wine.
You just don't like the taste of it.
Or 21st birthday.
I went out to dinner with my parents and
had a glass of wine and I had one sip
and spit it right back. I was so gross, I
couldn't handle, one's an acquired taste,
but I like it.
I don't know why people acquired tastes.
So I tried to acquire the taste
of caviar once I was on a plane,
they serve caviar and I'm like, okay,
I'll try this. I'm like, this is ass.
This is so stupid.
Why would anybody pay a lot of
money for this stupid tasting thing?
It tastes like, smells like,
tastes like warm smell. Like,
like after a rain looks like a weird
thing. Like, well it's not that bad,
but it's a weird thing.
I was like,
why don't we do acquire a taste
for something that's a Shitty,
unless it's like super
healthy, but wine I like, I,
I genuinely like it and I
think it's an acquired taste,
which I just contradicted myself.
But it goes well with certain things.
Like if you're eating like meat,
like steak,
like a big juicy red ribeye and you're
just chewing into that and you'd just
feel that blood and that texture and then
you have a little swig of Merlow to go
with that. Ah, it's probably the best
thing to put the whole entire world.
It's fucking good. Then
it's good. Then it's good.
Then it's just like they go
together somehow or another.
But if you just like hanging out with your
friends and it's hot outside and like,
let me get a glass of wine. I was
like, yeah, why do you want, you know,
you want me to it up
Gatorade or one you'd rather,
you'd probably have to
start off with wine coolers.
I think that's how everyone starts off
as drinking wine coolers and then one day
you go, I'm going to get a
chardonnay or Pinot Gris. Yes.
If I'm not interested in it.
Like what's the point in starting?
I feel like it only because it's
going to cause trouble in my life.
Wine's going to cause trouble.
Like drinking. I've never drank,
I've never been drunk. Well, you know,
there's, there's, there's that, I mean,
you could look at it that way or you
could look at it that you're not going to
have as much fun. Right? I mean, it
is true. These are, I mean, these are,
this is a legit way of looking at, I
mean, people will argue, you know what,
eagles sober people have
plenty of fun sober people.
I'm going to say this and I love you,
but you're not nearly as interesting.
It's not
all my funny friends,
all my fascinating friends all either
smoked pot or do mushrooms or do something
and they fuck around with their mind.
It's just everything in moderation.
And you know,
you don't have to not look at Stan hope.
There's no moderation there, right. It's
just everything while you're alive. Yeah.
But it should be, that's what you
should focus your whole entire life on.
Everything in moderation except like
heroin. But that's for me. And you may be,
but I think for other people,
they really don't mind burning the candle
at both ends and seeing how long it
takes til they die. Right. I mean, if
you really look at it all objectively,
it's like, you know, what is
this an 80 year trip, a 90
year trip? If you're lucky,
it ends for everybody.
If it's not that enjoyable,
isn't there an argument for a much more
enjoyable fucking completely chaotic 47
years? Oh my God. You know,
drugs and alcohol. Yeah.
Wait until you get your shit and
then you level off. I mean, look,
I'm not saying it's the way to go.
It's certainly not the way to go,
but it's a way to go. It's a
way to go. You know, and it's,
it's a way that's produced a lot of
pretty fucking incredible artwork. That's,
you know, every great
musician, every great comedian,
they've all fucked her head up.
They've all done it.
Every single one of them prior Kennison
Mitch Hedberg mean just go down,
stand hope, go down the line of all the
guys that I really appreciate watching,
they're all fucking either pot Ed's or
they've done a bunch of crazy shit and
lived a fucked up life. So it's not, I
mean, it's not your Yogi, Vegan, you know,
eating beans and sitting in
the Lotus position way to go.
But that way ends to man that way.
Fucking shits out. And you're,
you're crapping in your
fucking the loin cloth.
No,
that's the dilemma that I have is like
a lot of the comedians that I'm friends
with constantly tell me, you'll write
better, you'll be more creative.
So that's sort of what's making me,
it's made me consider it.
Well, it's also a testament
to your character though,
that you've got this thing in your head
where you don't want to be a fuck up.
Right. You know, it's like you have like,
like a plan or you have, uh, you know,
a guideline that it's like safe to operate
in. You know, you're looking at like,
I don't want to be a loser. I don't want
to be of this. I don't want to be that.
So I don't want to fuck around with drugs
and I don't want to be like all these
people. I mean, there's,
that's, that's legit too.
Have you ever become addicted to
something so drastically before that?
You're just, it scares you
to try things like, I mean,
you barely want to take Tylenol. You told
me, you know, like you don't like taking,
um, I'm not, it's not like I've ever
been addicted to anything crazy. Like no,
but I, I think my, okay.
Growing up, my parents,
I've never seen them drink,
they don't drink and they don't,
they don't smoke or it
just was never around it.
And also I think it comes
back to like high school,
all the cool people started drinking
and I was like, oh, I get it,
but I don't need to do that right now.
And I just sort of never started. Right.
You're a rebel and being
sober. Uh, yeah. I guess
you're fighting the status quo.
You guys want to drink and
party and have a good time.
I'm going to listen to Morrissey
and cry. Fuck you. Exactly, exactly.
And suffer from my art. No, I mean,
yeah, they're really surprise.
You're not really religious because it
seems fucked up and all these other ways.
How come you haven't followed Jesus?
Yeah. Do you think you'll ever find Jesus?
Is that right around the corner for you?
Brain is too big for that
whoa. Strong words. Well,
what do you think about scientists
and all these like really intelligent,
educated people that become Christians?
I, I don't know. I, if someone
provides me with evidence and proof,
I'll take a look at it. But I, I didn't,
I wasn't raised with any religion and I,
I mean I would like to believe in God and
I think that people that do believe in
God lead much happier, better lives
than I ever will. But I just can't.
Yeah, that's an interesting
thing, isn't it? Yeah.
That a lot of people who
are like Super Christian,
it's like they have the answer.
They have Deann word in their
head and because of that they,
they have like a piece
about them. They, you know,
they believe that this is going to end.
It's going to go onto the next thing.
And all this could be ironed out
if we just made IOWASCA legal.
If all these people that
have these religious ideas
of all these people that are
confused and don't know what the fuck's
going to happen if they really got a
chance to go over to the
spirit world and you can do it.
If you want to go to Peru,
do you want to go on a shamonic vacation?
You'd cross you like a few hundred bucks
and you get to stay in a hut for a few
days and then I'll just cook up Iowasca
and you'll sit around and drink it with
the Shaman and they'll blow tobacco
smoke in your face and you will fucking
travel to the spirit world where you will
get to see what it's like on the other
side. You will get to talk
to your dead ancestors.
You'll get to commune with mother Earth
and see the leopards in the fucking
jaguars and the snakes in the trees. You
could do it. Do you know what Iowasca is?
No.
Iowasca as this crazy jungle brew.
It's a good,
see,
it's a psychedelic brew that they've
made by combining two plants. And, uh,
these people have been taking it for
thousands and thousands of years and they
go over there and they have trips. Like
people gonna have trips. Like we're,
you know, they'll organize like big
vacations while they'll send 20,
30 people into the jungle.
And you know,
you've got to take a boat to
get to these fuckers. You know,
they're like living like people
been living for thousands
and thousands of years.
Very difficult to get to them. And then
you can do Iowasca with them. What, like,
who decides to go do that? A lot of
people do. They want to, you know,
there's a lot of people that have had,
see,
we don't think about it in this
country because it's all illegal.
All those drugs are schedule one drugs.
But in a lot of countries,
for thousands of years, everyone's
had these rite of passage, uh,
things in their life. You know. I
mean, for some people it's pain.
Like there's tribes in
the Amazon that they,
they have these gloves with bullet
ants in them. It's the craziest thing.
I, it's, I've, I've found it
online on Youtube. You can find it.
These guys did a bullet ant.
Apparently one aunt staying is like
literally getting shot by a bullet.
It's like my friend described it as like
feeling like he got his arms slammed in
a car door over and over again for hours.
He said is the,
is the most intense and excruciating pain
and they stick their hands into these
gloves that are filled with bullet ants
and they'd just the bull Jews Jack them
and they have to keep the gloves on for
like 10 minutes and then for hours and
hours during the in they're crying.
They're in incredible agony,
but these are rites of passages
and these rites of passage.
The idea is that you have
to have something that
perturbs your normal state of
consciousness, something that completely
blasts you out of this current,
like you know,
this mundane state of existence in
order to signify that you've made a
transition, like this is going to
be a very difficult thing to do.
But once you've done this very
difficult thing than the regular life,
normal life, you're going to
appreciate this so much more.
You're going to feel like,
like privileged,
you're gonna feel like you've made this
rite of passage. Like you've become,
someone evolved, you know, you've, you've,
you've reached the next level in the
video game. Well, with Iowasca, you know,
these,
these rituals were totally painless,
but psychologically very scary
for people because you're,
you're literally giving up control of
your consciousness and connecting to this,
this web of consciousness that's surrounds
every life form on the planet and
every life form that ever existed, they're
all interconnected somehow. And you,
you realize during the four
hours that you're on his trip,
you realize that my God,
like I'm like,
everything's insignificant.
It's not just that you're insignificant,
it's earth isn't significant,
but it's not as at the same time,
it's like it's all connected
in this weird, strange way
that we don't understand.
And that the way I was described as
that life might be just one frame and an
infinite movie that lasts
forever. You know? I mean,
you really do have to look at it like
that. Well, IOWASCA provides this vision.
IOWASCA provides you with this,
like this, this, this, this idea,
this way of looking at the world,
you know? And that's totally illegal.
It found interesting.
And it also sounds to me,
my first thought is very, very
dangerous. Yeah. But not see,
but the DMT,
the chemical that it makes is a chemical
to your own brain producers. Oh Wow.
So it's not, it's not dangerous at all.
I mean, nobody's dying from this stuff,
but people dying from cigarettes,
people dying from alcohol to dying from
a million different things that are not
worried about, you know,
but people are worried about
doing this crazy thing. Well,
this crazy thing is scary because
you're going to give up control,
you're going to go someplace,
you're gonna.
But that's what these rites of passages
are all about. That's what like really,
really figuring out, like really having a
better view of life. You know, like, uh,
like,
like you really feel like you're evolving.
One of the best ways to do that is to
just really objectively look at what this
life is, you know? And it's very
hard to do that while you're in it.
And what these psychedelic drugs do is
they pull you out of this life and they
let you look at it. I mean, if
they are religious experiences,
this is the root of all religious
experiences in psychedelics. I believe.
So you want to do it right
now? Try some. All right,
so these people who have all done these
like all throughout the past, you know,
um, I think that's probably
the original religious story.
And then somewhere along the line they,
they got twisted and more twisted more.
And then instead of
like seeing God as like,
like really God is us and we're all
together in this thing and it's this weird
sort of like insane momentum behind
like all life in the universe,
everything together,
all this one big thing.
But you can't really see it
in your everyday life and
allows you see it when you
did take entheogens are when you take
mushrooms or something like that.
And I think that's what that was the
original message while that shit.
So that's why religion is good for you.
I mean,
that's why religion like why
it can help you. Like why?
Like people that do it live a happier
life because in a way they're right.
I mean,
they're not really right that there's a
dude in the clouds with a harp and he's
got a book and Saint Peter Goes, so what
have you done while she, oh, you did this.
There's not that, it's not that, but there
is something else. I mean it's a very,
very likely that we are just
like one part of a much,
much, much bigger thing. Yeah. I
don't doubt that. I just write,
I guess I just don't believe in,
I don't like to hear people talk about
you're going to go to hell. Well that's,
that's, that's the negative aspect
of it. But the positive aspect,
I met a lot of Christians
that were really happy,
really nice people because they really
did believe that they were a part of
something bigger.
They really did believe that they were
doing the work of someone bigger and they
really are. I mean, it really is what
you're doing. Positive Shit. I mean,
although the, the ideals of Christianity,
the real ones are, you know,
love your brothers. You would
love yourself, don't commit crime,
don't commit murder. Don't fuck your
neighbor's wife. Like that kind of shit.
Like that's all. I'm a subscriber. There's
a lot of other stuff thrown in there.
Like you're allowed to have slaves
and beat your wife. But you know,
you got to know that some Douche bag
stuck that in there and they'll put the
teams up here right here,
50 slave and fucking in the ass,
you know, but, but the root of
it all, like the ideas behind it,
it's obviously clearly a guideline for
living life and being happy and creating
a harmonious culture.
I think that's good.
The root of all those almost positively
is come from psychedelic drugs for crazy
murderers,
monkeys that ran around and taking drugs
and they sat back and just went, whoa,
wait a minute. What are we doing
here? What is this? It's not just me.
It's not just you were a part of a Web,
a network. The trees are intelligent,
the dirt is alive, and they just have
this intense feeling for you know, five,
six hours or however long it is, depending
on how many mushrooms they've eaten.
And then they start to rethink. I'm turned
off by the word drugs like that. Yeah.
If you think about it like they're just
consuming things in nature and this is
happening. That's sounds a
little different too. Yeah.
Well that's cause we drugs,
you know the idea we've, you know, put
it as pills and that fuck your world up.
That's the problem is how can
you have one word for everything?
How can you have one word that includes
coffee and cigarettes and heroin.
You know like how are those together? How
has, how has coffee and meth together,
how are they in the same
drug? But they are. How was,
how was rockstar energy drink?
How is that and should have
it like a drug one through 10.
Like it's a trig Wu. But here's
the problem. Schedule One.
Schedule One is like the least
dangerous shit. It's marijuana. Heroin.
Like the laws are completely fucked up.
Mushrooms are scheduled one.
Nobody's dying off. They need to start
off a little bit slower than that though.
Needs to be like level one, like,
you know, at caffeine and you know,
it should go through all the drugs, you
know, he's like, that's a level six I had,
she'd be logical.
Yeah,
I have.
I think I'm such a control freak.
Like I've heard people talk about
mushrooms and it sounds like, oh,
you go through this exciting
experience and that's really cool,
but what if I'm like,
I don't know.
I feel like I would just get freaked
out and be like, take it away.
Like make it stop.
You might, because that's what happens
if you try to control the trip. Yeah.
If you are really worried
and you, you know, look, you,
what you're doing is very difficult.
Okay. You're a single girl,
you're 22 years old and you're committing
to do stand up comedy in Los Angeles
and you're, you weigh about 35 pounds
and you look like you're 12. I mean,
what you're doing is,
that's a fucking dangerous thing.
Did you have any friends out here?
Um, yeah, my best friend from college.
Yeah. And so you moved out here with her,
with him and met him here. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, you know, what you're doing is very,
very risky and I bet
your mind in your mind,
you want to minimize all the
outside risks as much as possible.
Glare. Yeah. And I like, I'm not against
it morally at all. I mean if I, you know,
I've achieved nothing so far,
so it's like once I start to get
somewhere and feel accomplished,
I'm sure that I will sit back
and like take a hit of something.
Right. No, I totally
know what you're saying.
I totally know where you're coming
from. When I was a kid, um, uh,
when I did martial arts, I never
did any drugs. I never did anything.
I hate only drunk or gotten drunk.
Maybe like I could count on my hands
and my fingers like maybe eight,
nine times in my whole high school
career. You know, it was like, oh,
my friends would be fucking hammered
all the time. I'd be going to parties,
but I don't even,
it was eight times.
So it's probably less than that all
throughout high school. All I did was,
so I always thought the same way. I
always thought that drugs are for losers.
Yeah. Alcohol and drugs and you
know, want to smoke cigarettes,
you're going to be a zero.
It's gonna fuck you up.
And you know it just until I was
like 30 that I smoke pot again.
Yeah. I think I may be done at
once or twice, like over the years,
like drunk at a party or something
like that. But it was never like, Ooh,
I'm going to smoke pot and
like think about shit. Never.
I would never even think of that.
It'd be like, you fucking loser.
You need pot to think about
shit you fucking pussy. Like
that's was my mentality.
But it was the same reason. It was
like, I was like hyper control freak.
I was trying to like be successful.
I didn't want to be a loser.
I was gonna fucking go out there and I
had a very similar attitude that you do,
you'll about all these, this anger that
you have towards these hot chicks. Yeah.
You know, I mean, I had that same
thing, you know, with towards, you know,
I don't know who it was.
It was a lot of different people.
I'd probably have an Asian man, much less
specific. No, I've always enjoyed fine.
I really nice guys.
Um,
as I totally know where you're coming
from. Don't let anybody talk you into it.
But the idea is once you become like a
little bit more stable with your life,
you know, then you start
considering the idea of, you know,
just fucking around
with your consciousness.
You don't have to do dangerous shit
though. Yeah. Start off slow. Yeah.
Start off with shotgunning
we'd Af you know,
whatever with another person
and then next move on to,
if you're going to smoke weed, just
moat. Know who you're smoking a weapon.
Just smoke a tiny bit. Yeah, just
like a little baby hit or no,
because then you'll just be like,
ah,
you just be like relaxed and silly and
then you'll just have cool conversations
and you won't be paranoid. You know, like
so many people come to me and they go,
dude, I tried pot. You was
listening to you. I tried pot.
I got fucking super paranoid man. I told
he fucking freaked out. I couldn't drive.
I had to stay at my friend's
house for like eight hours.
His wife has tried to kick me out like
it's always this terrible, terrible story.
And Mike Gamble, you got
to high stupid. Yeah.
You weren't supposed to smoke
five joints here first time.
That's supposed to fucking a time travel.
Right.
You know when you smoke too much
weed bend, you just lose time.
We just ended up in play when I was in
high school. I got super, super high.
Me and my friend Josh and my girlfriend,
there was one time that I
deviated from my plan and uh,
we were like 15 and my stepfather
had weed and it was really good weed.
My stepfather was a super hippie who
was like long hair, computer programmer,
the whole deal.
And he had some bomb ass weed and uh,
it was one of the reasons also
that I never smoked weed. This is,
I just always assumed that it was terrible
for you because of this experience.
So we were over my girlfriend's house
and we smoked this pot and then we would
just appear in rooms. I was like
blip and now I'm in the kitchen.
How do I get the kitchen blip
now I'm on the couch. I mean,
we were all doing this.
I mean we were our little 15 year old,
weak ass brains were way to just,
there's no way we had the experience
to deal with this kind of weed. It was,
it was craziness. And from then on
I was like, I could just be fucking,
I just wake up and traffic driving, you
know, like what if, what if that happened?
What if I have flashbacks, you
know, to me I considered like, wow,
I've dodged that bullet. I learned
the pots for losers, you know,
it's not even the case. My, I didn't
get stone the first time I did it.
I like would get stone like three times
or something like that and nothing would
ever happen.
And then finally one day I got to stone
and I just wanted to watch cartoons all
day. You should try it. And
it's good for your asthma.
Even though you say it's
bad for your asthma,
it's actually really good
for your ass. It's, the smoke
is not good for asthma. No,
no,
you don't have to smog it too.
There's a thing called a
vaporizer and they brought her,
just makes mist and when it makes us miss,
it's really pretty cool. The missed. Um,
like it seems like,
like you're blowing fog almost out of
your mouth and like a lot of people go to
d because they're like, I don't even,
I mean I'm feeling there's no smoke.
Like they feel like they're not
getting enough. But you are,
you're getting the burned off
THC crystals only for you.
You'd want only like
three volcano bags full.
Three full bags of volcano. Definitely.
Good for you to contemplate to his,
I'm thinking about jumping off a bridge.
We'll start freaking the fuck out.
I saw the craziest thing. I saw her do
stand up the other day and I you about it.
But it
was amazing. Uh, there was,
what does it? Saddle ranch. Oh,
it was like the worst audience ever.
It was just people rowdy,
not paying attention. The comments
were chatting on sunset? No,
it was a universal universal center and
there was even comic right next door to
John Lovitz his club. Yes. There's like
a little standup thing going on. Yeah.
And so like there,
there's even stand up comics.
They're just waving their legs and
their arms while they're on stage.
Just trying to get attention.
It wasn't that bad. Wow.
And then she gets on stage and
everyone just, it was weird.
Everyone just shut up and then started
applauding and clapping and it was
amazing. I've never seen somebody
Turner room around biker and like,
I saw three comics go up and fail.
And how,
how good were the comics
that went up before? Uh,
I mean they were pretty good if
you were to listen to their jokes.
I'm not saying they're the best or
anything, but they're decent, you know.
And then the two guys from,
uh, ways that repo man. Yeah.
And I dunno the show. Yeah. Yeah.
Like these big buff guys
that have to have some true
TV. There's only one repo man. It's
with Emilio Estevez bitches. All right.
I'm not watching your shelter.
You change the fucking name. Okay.
You can't be repo man. Yeah. Kevy
even repo men, that's done. You know.
Totally even want to say
Cosell repossession ink.
That's cool. You can't change.
Make the name of your show one of the
greatest cult movies ever and then make a
cheap fake. Yeah. You're cheating you
cons. Yeah. You're making it fake. Yeah.
You Fox. So what about a
reality show? Asked her,
would you be down for that following
little Esther around? No, I don't know.
I guess would while little Esther,
how about this?
How about a reality show
with you and Brian were,
Brian just gets you to do terrible,
terrible things like that video
you guys made. What is it?
Where can people find out if you've got
a little esther.com she has her on there.
It's called an Ester is spelled with a t.
H. E. S. T. H. E. R. Yeah.
[inaudible] dot com and a,
it's a video of Brian
literally legitimately getting
her to try cigarettes for
the first time. Alcohol for the first
time. He got you to try all these things.
Like I just stepped it though. And I
barely am hailed the cigarette and yeah,
it was, it just reaffirmed everything. I
already, I'm like, this tastes discussing,
this makes me feel sick.
Like it reaffirmed everything.
The only thing he liked was the
shoplifting. One guy, she went back,
sack tee times. It's like, I'm just
doing more shit from this place. I
shoplifting. I just said, did you
stop it for real gummy bears? Like,
you know how they have all the candy
out and really did shoplifting. Yeah.
Took a few pieces of candy. Whoa. Yeah.
And we'd go to jail for that. Right.
You're talking about they're middle men
again. I thought it was just a setup.
They were samples. Okay. Okay.
I was free. Right. It was legit.
I think there's like a uncalled law
that you're allowed to sample a,
when you go to those candy shops,
you're allowed to sample one to see if
you want to buy it. They have it open.
It's like a little gummy bear that's
not really shoplifting. Oh, okay.
It is though, because if everyone
just knows one stove, gummy bears,
everyone's told gummy bears. I
smoked cigarettes, uh, when I was 15,
I smoked one and I didn't like it and
I just, I was like, this is disgusting.
My sister won up getting hooked and that
was another, it showed me like, okay,
this is obviously not good.
And then when I was about
23, I did some, there was
like a bunch of comics,
they were doing some sketches and we
were trying to put together some sketches
and one of the characters was this guy
who was like this cigarette smoking,
like um,
like poet guy who was like,
what was writing terrible poetry and
smoking cigarettes all the time and like
smoking, like, so I had to play that guy
and I was like smoking the cigarette.
Like I smoked cigarettes all day while
we rehearsed this and my hands were
shaking,
my whole body was freaking out.
I must've smoked like
at a no cigarettes ever.
I must've smoked like seven
cigarettes. That's crazy, dude.
I was shaking. I was shaking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like,
and I couldn't talk all that good.
It was like my words are coming out.
It was like I needed breasts in
between my words. I was like,
Dow fucking crazy that people suck
down two packs these things a day.
Whoo.
That's a,
that is the biggest mind fuck in the
history of our society is that cigarettes
are not just legal,
but that cigarette and tobacco
companies are allowed to send money to
politicians and put politicians in office
and contribute to their funds so that
the politicians support them and give
them good laws and make sure that they can
continue to sell their shit and
stores everywhere. You know?
Meanwhile they're killing hundreds
of thousands of people a year.
I can't even think about it as
it so crazy. Like if something,
if something gives you cancer,
like if they find out the diet coke no
fucks you up or something like that,
you've got to get rid of it.
You got to pull it off the market.
It's a fact for sure that cigarettes
fuck you up. It's so disgusting.
I can't handle.
I like their new commercial for like
the nonsmoking thing where it was like
broken glass, you know, we're
recalling broken glass and he was like,
only if co companies, you know, recalled
products that wasn't, uh, you know,
they should read recall
cigarettes the same way. You know,
it's all about that money,
man. It's all about the money.
There's too much money on cigarettes.
It's a multibillion dollar industry.
People like them and I support the,
if you really want to have a cigarette,
you should be able to do whatever
the hell you want to do. You know,
if you want to smoke. So I like cigars.
Kevin James and I smoke cigars sometimes.
He's the only one that really struck
them with, he likes, you know, Ari,
Ari and I smoke cigars or mature for
cigars. Look man, they taste good.
I like it. It's, again,
it's an acquired thing.
It's like you can enjoy it if you have
a big fat fucking piece of meat and sit
down with a big cigar. It's
fun. But you could do it.
You should be able to do
whatever the fuck you want.
But the idea that you know that this isn't
like something that people are trying
to stop.
The idea that you have these people that
are politicians but they're not like
coming out and saying Lazy Jen, we'll
do it. We've got a real issue here.
We're losing loved ones were getting sick.
We're losing time on the job.
This is costing employers money like and
it's costing you your enjoyment of this
time here you're addicted.
This little fucking country cigarette man,
we've got to stop this
shit at the same time.
No one's unaware that that's what it's
like. Yeah they are, but we were babies.
We need someone to step up
and say it. You know, if they,
if all of a sudden you know
the fluids in the news,
all they have to do is put the flu in
the news and say we have to be careful to
wash your hands and this and that.
The flu is in the news and then everybody
goes home. The fluids in the news.
You knew about the fucking flu.
Goddammit.
The is always coming every goddamn winter.
It's the same thing. It's a new flu.
This year. It's the pig flu. Next year
it's the bird flu. It's a fucking flu.
You get sick every year. Well, you know,
don't touch things that shitheads touch.
Wash your hands. Take probiotics,
eat acidophilus in yogurt.
Take care of your body.
Take your vitamins, get some
sleep. It's all fucking,
we all know it, but we need to
hear it. We need to hear it.
We need daddy to tell us though. Flu.
Get your flu shot. Ladies and gentlemen,
Wash your hands. You can use this. This
is PRL. This kills 99% of all bacteria.
I like your purple bottle that's on
this couch. It's like parral with shit.
Like on the bottle. That's
probably chocolate. It's like
a joke. That right there.
The joke. It's like the cleanest
solution is covered with poop.
It doesn't look like poop. Oh,
you know what it is actually,
it looks like a piece of tape that's been
peeled off at the sticky stuff is here
and the sticky stuff is accumulated.
A bunch of dirty things. Yeah.
Hmm. Ah, so good point though, Brian.
Just going to put this on my ball back.
So it feels like,
so if you were to ever do a show where
it made you just try a bunch of things,
would you like if you
got paid for that show,
would you do things like that you would
never do? Like, like eat a raw, you know,
medium rare steak. Would you uh, you know,
try to be a stripper for a day or
you know, like do shit like that?
I wouldn't do like weird, weird stuff.
Like I wouldn't not, you brought me,
that sounds really not even like
if you were being paid for it,
like each episode you're getting $5,000. I
don't know. That's a really, uh, I'm, no,
why not?
Cause I like to use my brain,
but you're that afraid of me.
I'm not, I've eaten meat. I mean,
and every now and then I'm
like, okay, yeah, I'll have
a bite of that cheeseburger.
But, so I'm not like super strict
and I grew up eating meat a lot.
What made you stop eating meat?
I'm just kind of reading different books
and getting bored and just trying to
learn different things and yeah,
I really miss about health health,
some main reason. Yeah. So,
so you're like very concerned with making
sure that your life is in order. Yeah.
Very concerned with your health
and very concerned with, you know,
don't doing anything dangerous and
your future and everything like that
basically.
Is that to offset all the danger you
take in this fucking crazy risky career?
I think so. Yeah. And I mean, I
also don't, I don't know. You don't,
you don't, you can't
trust many people. I mean,
I'm hanging out at comedy clubs till three
in the morning where everyone else is
a guy and in their thirties and you had
been trying to take advantage of you. Oh,
well I think that goes without
saying. Really. No. I mean, no,
no one does anything crazy.
But I mean,
they'll try to kiss you when
you didn't want it. Yeah.
We all might say names. Yes, that happens.
So we know the story.
So you were in speaking of or you were
in Don [inaudible] Dingdong show or were
you in the no, I was on the
Dingdong show. I was in,
he has a band called the bears Kennedy
overdrive that I was a part of for a year
and a half actually. That's the air
guitar band. Yes. They, they pretty much
our a part of for a year and
a half. Yeah. As Jesus Christ.
How much patience do you have is actually
really uh,
integral like part of my comedy career
I guess because I like developed a lot.
I got a lot of stage time.
I was there every night to like sometimes
three in the morning was even no one
in the audience.
And like I played this character that's
actually had a little Esther videos sort
of came about because I play this
character that, you know, don goes,
is there any a dancer in the audience?
And I'd be like,
be sitting in the audience
like, Oh, I can do it.
And then on stage and everyone's like, oh
my God, who let the 14 year old in here?
And like it just wouldn't just
improvised stuff every night.
And it was actually a pretty cool and
so you were doing this even without an
audience? Um, yeah there
would be audiences a lot,
but some nights there were not
audiences and wow. Don is very,
he's a die hard performer and he's one
of the smartest people I think ever.
He's so funny and there's very fine
cheese is a great guy. Oh my God,
he's so funny. He's so weird. He's
crazy. And he's just like literally,
I feel so lucky that I got to develop
with him cause he's definitely like made a
big part of the character.
So you developed this
character doing that, right.
And then so that is who you
are when you go on stage. No,
you're you when you go on stage.
Yeah.
Which is really weird because
like when I first met her,
she was the little character person.
And so like I thought all right,
this girl is like a little girl
and then you meet the adult person.
It's so weird cause you're, you
are like uh, you play like you're,
you trick yourself into
thinking you're a kid.
Yeah. I mean I guess it's
more, let's honestly,
it's probably more like
multiple personality disorder
and don't say anything.
Maybe bipolar. No, I
don't know. I just like,
sometimes I act like a kid and I just
get into it and I commit to it yet.
Okay. What's the trauma? There's
no, what has gotten you into this,
this form of a performance and
communication? What it was gotten.
You understand the economy something.
Huh?
My, I'm trying to figure it out.
My theory and you can tell her,
my theory is that one day she's going to
like drop her car keys and bend down to
pick it up and there's going to be this
huge flash in her head and she's going
to remember all this shit that
she's totally blacked out.
I literally have no idea.
I'm be a scientist with your theories.
Doesn't it seem like it's something like
that would happen like the $6 million
man for guy. My Dad used to
kiss me on the tummy too hard.
You know the problem with those,
those types of memories that like,
you know,
Roseanne's that or she remembered being
molested when she was two or something
like that. You're real memories
from back then are a ghost,
you know, your, your body first
of all isn't even the same body.
Every single cell in your body
changes over every seven years.
So a lot of times you're, they don't
even know where the memories are stored.
The only, the only options
are that it's not a local,
but the memories are somewhere out in
the ether and you can tune into them and
access them like a cloud,
which is ridiculous.
And then the other option is that they're
in the neurons because the neurons are
the only things that don't get
swapped out, like with cells.
I do remember being breastfed.
Do you? Yeah, I really,
yeah. I was breastfed really
late years. Three and a half,
three and a half years old.
Most people do. At what, six
months is the Max usually?
Sometimes three. My wife does
it for a year. A year? Yeah.
Three and a half years ago.
She remembers it being done though.
Really good for you. Yeah. I have
one memory of being brown. Oh,
there's a woman that I know who did
it to her four year old. Wow. Yeah.
Four years old. Four years
old. The kid would get upset.
She would just worry about a tip. But can
you, can you imagine remembering at Joe?
Can you remember?
No,
I have heard that people can remember
really in depth things about their
childhood.
I have some distant ghostlike
memories from being very young,
like five and four and
three and one very clear.
One of her very traumatic moment
when I was young I was about five,
but the other ones are like goes,
what's your traumatic moment?
My Dad beat the shit out my mom. Right,
right, right. No mine. The youngest,
I can remember my mom says I was three
and a half for my great grandmother was
sitting on this bench across this like
a farm field and I guess there was a,
a nes ate chicken nest or
something like that nearby. Uh, uh,
I think it was chickens and I was walking
towards her and I got too close and
then like maybe five chickens
like attacked me. Like,
like I just remember my great
grandmother being too old going, yeah.
Oh help him.
He's getting attacked
cause she could walk over and stuff like
that. And I just remember my mom here,
my mom would go,
oh my God.
And she runs up and gets
all these chickens off me
and I had like bloody phase
and everything like that. How old were
you? I think like three and a half.
Four to went on a chicken slaughter.
Rampy yeah.
I would have killed those chickens with
baseball bats, but that was my kid.
I would have smashed all
those little cunty chickens.
I remember cause one hit
me right in between you and
they kind of got your eyes,
just chickens get sick if once you can
get sick and he falls to the ground,
right? Yeah. The chickens will just
pick at it. Death. Really? Yeah.
They'll peck the dead. They'll start
eating and eating his eyeballs.
He in his brain. Yeah. Pack the
shit out of him. Chickens are cuts.
What's your most dramatic moment from your
childhood as the youngest? You can go,
I can't even think of any thing.
Okay.
So do you think that the trauma was all
being ostracized by the cool kids and
that you know,
being forced on the outside and forced
to think that you're a piece of shit and
you're not special and so then you
have this motivation to show that your
specialty, your performer, that you can
make it, that you could be successful?
I think I, but I also think at
too comes from like my family.
My mom is Christian and my dad's
Jewish and my mom has like this big,
a big family with like a lot of cut.
There's cousins and aunts and whatever.
And I always sort of felt like I was like
the one Jew like that no one liked and
they'd like,
I was not included in a lot.
And I think that is like mostly it
because it's school. When I was little,
I was finally, I was like a leader in
like my teachers always said like, oh,
Esther's kind of bossy and people follow
her around like so I know that I was
confident early on,
but I think like just having a family
where I felt like I wasn't a part of what
they were a part of made me feel like,
well then I don't care and I'm going
to do my own weird stuff. And so yeah,
that seems pretty active.
So you,
you felt almost like as a young kid,
because they're one side of the family
was not Jewish and you're Jewish and you
had, you couldn't mix in, you felt
there was other Jewish people,
they just didn't like her.
That's what you're saying. No,
cause she's saying your mom's
side, right? The Non Jews. I don't,
but I didn't really associate it with
being Jewish. Now I do a little bit,
even though that might not be fair
of me to say, but it's like I just,
I didn't really fit in with
everyone. So your, your mom
was Jewish. Christian. Okay.
So you weren't raised Jewish
though. So you're not a Jew? No.
So what are you saying that I, my
dad's a Jew. Right. But at your camp,
you're not a Jew. Technically have to, but
you're not Jewish religious wise. Right.
He comes from the mother.
But people that are not Jewish,
if they know that you're have one
Jewish parent, it's sort of like, Oh,
you're a Jew. A lot of
people are like that. Yeah.
Jewish people say I'm not Jewish
and non Jewish people say that I am.
No one wants me in their group. Wow,
you've got this thing, you've got this.
I'm on the outside looking in thing.
I do.
I sort of like the, the Rogan board
posts will start coming in. Whoa.
George try to cycle.
Why isn't he doing it?
Doctor Phil Voice through a girl on the
show call called, Oh my God, there's,
they said so many mean things about me.
They're like,
she's 20 Felix 25 and she's
like a weird child lady
cleaning my house. Oh, I understand.
It's okay.
And then one said that I have the face
of a 14 year old and the stomach of a 34
year old.
That is rude to you,
that motivate you in any way? They want
to go to the gym, do some crunches.
I do want to go to the gym. Yes. But I um,
I mean being in stand up like one of
my comedy mentors is Ari Shaffir and he
constantly tells me that I'm, that I'm
like need to lose weight like I'm used to.
Yeah, he tells you that.
Was he talking to him?
I wrote him this text message cause we
had the same agent. I'm like all right my,
our agent said that cause I put that
little extra video out and he was like,
he said that that video is going to hurt
me and it's dirty and things they're
going to ban me from the casting directors
won't talk to me and our response
back was lose weight.
Wow.
Did he say something like you will
always be no, he told me, he's like,
you're going to die alone and it's going
to be your fault. He's so mean to him,
but I enjoy it. I don't know. I
think it's, I think it's funny.
He's funny when he's mean instead of
Juju thing you think or do you think that
is how he talks to ladies?
That's how I talked to the lady.
He knows you don't want him,
so he's lashing out at the same way you
do with those hot chicks, I guess. Yeah,
and every time like a hot check, I'll walk
by. He's like, she taught her than you.
[inaudible] is rude,
but the good thing about that kind of
rude thing amongst friends is when you
hear it from someone else,
let's try to hurt your feelings,
but it doesn't work at all. Shut up
stupid. Yeah. I got this the first time
I've heard that dummy.
Exactly. Yeah. All right.
Do you ever say anything negative to
him? Not really. I'm pretty nice. I,
I've got some ideas, some shit down
for claim to give you some information.
Shit's discuss. So I bought hall
and you haven't seen Jew clam.
If you just googled Jew
cloud, it is. You should.
Fear has had apparently ferocious
hemorrhoids his entire life and they have
malformed his bottle.
He says it's all back to normal now,
but I don't believe him. I don't even
think he knows what the fuck normal is.
He always thinks it's supposed to
feel like sitting on bubble gum. Yeah.
It's like you remember that chick that
got her face bitten off by the chimpanzee?
Yeah, we fixed it. We fixed your
face paint. No, fixing that bottle.
That thing is, I don't
know what happened, but uh,
so you've seen his bottle on a video?
Yeah.
So he didn't take that it would hurt your
career at this, you being dirty stuff?
No. Most a lot of people, all
the comics don't think it will.
I mean the Disney channel
probably won't look at me anymore.
You don't need that shit. You're funny.
If you're funny, just keep doing comedy.
Keep doing what you think is funny.
Look at Sarah Silverman.
She's dirty as foxes and everything.
Selling fucking books are in the New York
Times bestsellers and movies is always
on television. You know, you don't have
to be clean. Yeah. That's nonsense.
That's if what that's all
that is is people with a,
they're shortsighted with limited
imagination that are trying to sell you.
That's all it is.
They think that they have to sell you as
someone who squeaky clean. Why the why?
That's what everybody else is doing. You
know what, what is your personality like?
What's coming out of your own brain and
obviously your brain is very complicated.
It's not going to be right down the
middle and squeaky clean and always,
you know, fucking softball
bullshit, you know,
whatever the fuck's on your
mind, what it out, you know,
it's harder and it's easier. It's harder
for a little bit because you know,
then people were like,
why is she swearing?
I don't like when she talks about cock,
but then after a while,
you know it's good because you're like,
hey,
you want to go see that
little list or yeah, I love,
she talks about car people know and then
they'll go see it and look forward to
it.
You need to talk about cock on stage more.
I don't actually ever super
clean onstage. Yes. Wearing no.
I mean sometimes it will slip out, but
because that video is pretty dirty. It is.
But I don't say anything dirty. And the
video is [inaudible] dot com as well.
Yeah. I just make other people
say dirty things, right? Yeah.
But you're pretty demented onstage though.
How am I diminishing like squeaky
clean? Like, Hey, we went,
did I wear my heart on my sleeve?
Like I'm very much whatever mood I'm in,
I just go,
well that sounds like fun.
I'm going to cunty mode.
I didn't want to pee up here performing,
but that's what he does really want
to fuck me, whatever like that.
But sometimes you have to be like that
to discover things. Hmm. That could
true.
Or it could be an excuse
for not controlling your
behavior that you look at it.
Like why I don't want to be organized.
Because if I was organized
and I wouldn't be creative,
a lot of people like they don't develop
discipline and they don't do the things
they're supposed to do and they'll somehow
or another justified in their head,
well, hey then this is how I discover
this is high. Take chances up there.
It's like the brilliant
point actually. But I, I'm,
I'm working on my organizational skills,
but no,
I sometimes you have very prepared
things and sometimes I'm just like,
I'm going to, I just want to try
and riff as much as possible.
I think that's a great thing.
I riff a lot.
I do a lot of question and
answer stuff on my shows.
But what's important to me is I got to
go on stage with a good frame of mind.
You know,
it's very important but I mean you're
talking probably like these 45 minute sets
or whatever. I'm talking like a three
minute potlucks out of the comedy store.
Like I might be in a country mood, but
even that like why, why go up there then?
Why, you know, I mean yes and no. I mean
why not take some chances? Who knows?
But it's not like that
all the time at all.
I've had friends that have had real
problems with not being able to regulate
their state of mind before they
go on stage. And like you'll,
you'll have some sets that are great.
And then other sets where
you can tell there's like,
there's like some disconnect between
them and the audience. You know,
we had a buddy that was going through
a long stretch of shitty sets and he
wasn't telling us what apparently his
girlfriend had broken up with them and
moved out and he didn't tell us and we,
we were were like,
what the fuck is wrong with this dude?
Like when you talk to him,
he's like barely there. It's like,
it's weird like something's going on.
And then one day, you know, we were eating
and he told us the whole story. I'll,
she broke up with me
and this and I'm like,
we were going to say anything like you
fucking Weirdo. Like for like months,
you know, we're like a, so that
was a check. Everything good. Yeah,
everything's great shit.
And meanwhile we were wondering what
this dude was falling apart on stage,
you know, like kind of harness
that and talk about the breakup.
Then you create a lot more
stuff if you're saying,
but especially if you're a man.
A lot of times the problem with men is
when men get dumped, it's like their,
their,
their reason for existing is like there,
it gets questioned. For a lot
of men, like when they're there,
they're worth is like gone to zero. You
know, they, they don't feel valuable.
They feel like a loser. You
know, like a man gets dumped,
a woman leaves him for another man. She
takes off and like your step by yourself,
like you don't feel worthy
to go on stage and talk.
You don't feel like anything you have
to say is valid. Like you're a zero.
Like that chick just broke up with you
and she's probably got another dude's
Dick in her mouth right now and you're
thinking about this and you're like, fuck.
And you,
you know,
you make mistakes and you call her or
trying to get her back and he say stupid
shit. Like let's just try one
more time. And then she says no.
And then she hangs up the phone. You're
like, what the fuck? I'm just a loser.
And then tried going onstage right then
and there and they're ready. Go, you know,
ladies and Gentlemen, please welcome
Mike mcfuck stick and Mike like,
fuck stick goes up there and just
eat shit. I've had to do that,
but I've never done to anyone. I always
get broken up with really always. Oh,
I've only had like four boyfriends,
but wow. Well, you know what?
You're going to get the opportunity to
dump this new one. You can. You could,
you could fucking pull the strings
on this one. This can be your first.
What are you guys talking about? I don't
know. Her just got some new boyfriend.
It's really cool to have the black. Did
they blocked in big, big block too. Um,
have you ever dated a black guy? No.
No you wouldn't. What about a mud race?
What's the Monterrey one?
Just make sure if you're an ignorant
racist in some, I don't know
Brown people. No, I'm not an ignorant
racist. I'm just making jokes.
You know, some jungle dude. Some fucking,
I don't know. I don't date on this date.
A dude from Vietnam? I don't think
so. I don't know. I ever meet. Yeah.
And wouldn't choose smoke cigarettes?
No.
What do you look for in
a guy besides red hair
from, um, I don't know. I don't
really look for things in guys.
I just, if a guy like is, I don't know.
There's nothing. I have no answer.
What's it like going from Chicago?
Meaning like Chicago guys,
regular dudes eating sausage and shit.
Well, I'll say this. I went literally
two and a half years in college.
No boy ever hit on me and I was like,
no,
I didn't even kiss anyone. Like I was
two and a half years in college. Yeah.
In College. Pillows get fucked. Everything
gets fucking college. But I didn't,
I didn't drink, I didn't
go out. I wasn't social.
I was really into comedy and stuff then.
But I mean sit in like meat guys
during doing the comedy stuff.
Not really.
Not of interest to you or then?
I think both. Really? Yeah. I mean I
went to like one of the big 10 schools.
So there's all these like really
pretty Midwestern like sweet girls.
Yeah. Why? Like all those
guys, the sorority people,
you know, people go from them losers.
I'm like there, I'm like the weird
nerd. And did you ever do comedy
at a Sorority? No, I didn't. No,
no, I was living in Boston. I did a
fraternities couple times. Really? Yeah.
Yeah. It was just like basements
and shit. Go down the handle,
like a little mic set up and 50 dudes
in a room and tell call me strange.
There's a lot of places to do comedy.
When I lived in Boston,
there was a ton of like satellite rooms
and bar rooms and you got to get all
kinds of different looks. You know how
you're talking about the saddle ranch,
you know, those, those are
terrible shows to do. Yeah.
But they're good shows to do to, you know,
up to a certain point. Some guys just,
I remember, uh, um, who the fuck was it?
Freddy? Freddy Soto was the first
one to say it. He, uh, you know,
he was a very funny guy that
passed away a few years ago,
but he was a comedy store regular. And
dudes would always be like, Hey Freddy,
I'm doing a show at, you know, the Mikes
pub down the street on Tuesday nights.
You know, and you want to come by and do a
set. And He'd be like, thank you. But uh,
you know,
I only do comedy clubs like I'm done.
I'm done with all that nonsense because
the nonsense the have to deal with when
you're doing comedy in a non comedy club,
you know,
the bar and the noise and people talk
and especially in Hollywood, you know.
But those are good too.
Yeah.
Oh yeah. I mean I'm desperate for
that right now. Stage is stage time.
It's, I'll take what I can get. But yeah,
I definitely prefer the comedy
club setting. I mean who wouldn't,
but don't you think that it's
good to do those shitholes yeah.
Cause it makes you like really
grab people's attention. Yeah.
I mean you have to really command everyone
in the room and also you have to just
sort of deal with the fact that some
people are not going to pay attention to
you and they're going to drink
and they're going to heckle.
And they're going to shout, show me your
tits. And you know, stuff like that.
You just, it's, it's part
of that and it's, it's fun,
but it also will show me your tits. No,
no, no. You don't know. But I laugh at,
I don't hate it. I'm like, okay,
you're drunk and you think that that's
funny if you say it so I understand and
you don't know how to be
funny in another way. Wow.
Cut it down. You break it down like
guys just sitting there like was
from Iowa so we roll.
Yeah.
Girls on stage and say show us
your tits cause you never know.
I'm just taking a chance. You did
all the Improv classes too, right?
Like the second city and shit.
Like a bio in Chicago and travel and Joe,
what does that,
it's like, it used to be called Improv
Olympic. It's like where Chris Farley,
all those Improv people.
Yeah.
And you were just going to
give us the abbreviation.
Like everybody knew what the fuck
you were talking about. They,
I think [inaudible],
I think they just call it Iot are not
allowed to call it some kind of like
Olympic lawsuit Olympic or
Improv Olympic really can,
you can have a club Improv
with all the comedy clubs.
I would think that that
would be more of an issue.
Well I think Olympics is actually like a
ne, isn't it? An Olympics? Like a name?
Like it's like a coca cola.
Yeah. Oh is it really? Yeah.
So it's called Io trademark the
Olympics because I think they made it,
didn't that, wasn't it around in the
Greek days? Oh yeah, no. Yeah, it wasn't.
It was it. Yeah. The Olympic cows. Oh,
how long does the Olympic
Games are going on for?
Was a lot of Roman numerals connects,
you know, you look at that, that's like,
someday there's going to be UFC in Roman
numerals is getting too many numbers.
Totally have to go with centuries,
two x's and shit.
Did you ever think to like maybe try like
a Saturday night live skit or is that
something you wanted to do?
Like kind of like a, you know,
like a live Improv? Yeah,
totally. I mean, I grew up
watching that show. That's like,
would you prefer to goal like a comic
or would you still be a comic or is it,
is it the comic thing that you,
I dunno. I mean I, I'm playing
everything by ear. You know,
I don't know what's going to happen with,
but I'm interested in all of it.
I just like getting on stage and making
people laugh and being myself. Right?
So I'm playing characters too,
but right now I think it comes in phases.
Sometimes I'm more
interested in what can I,
what character can I create and what
can I do? And then other times I'm like,
I just want to be myself and talk and
what are my thoughts and how can I get
them out there? And that's sort of
what I'm in right now. Just stand up.
It's way harder for a way harder
for a girl to get into comedy.
Way Harder when you're on stage,
people don't want to hear you talk.
A lot of men do not want to hear a
woman talk for 10 minutes or an hour.
And how many dudes want to go pay to see
Ellen degenerates do comedy, you know,
three to know that aren't
gay. You can come on. Really.
I mean it's like one of those. I mean,
you might, I would, I would have a dad.
She's good. You know
what I'm saying? Like,
it's like you have some no name woman
headliner at the Improv in Cleveland.
Good fucking luck selling
tickets. Good luck. It's conti.
Mcgillicuddy from fucking from
nowhere. Where's she been? Well,
she was on comedy central wants. Wow.
Yeah, whatever. Let's go to the movies.
You know, it's very hard to sell
tickets. It's very hard at black.
I though the like, look at that black guy.
Probably funny. I'll take a chance. Yeah.
Black Man. Probably
funny, right? White girl.
The fuck is she got to say
since this silly bitch out
to say what's your favorite
comics? Um, I really
into Louis C K right now.
I love his show. Louie.
Yeah. Great. Great.
Great question for me to add.
So what I was saying about, but
girls doing comedy, like you,
you don't get as many different things
you're allowed to talk about either you
can't have opinions on,
you can't call people don when it comes
to politics or opinions on, you know,
the president or opinions on
the way the world should be run.
Like you enter into like a danger zone
where there's knee jerk reactions where
people automatically don't want
to hear a young girl with opinion.
Right? Well already. Yeah,
because I look so young people sort of
don't trust that I have a brain and on
top of the fact that I'm a girl. But so
I mean, luckily like I'm not right now,
at least where I am, I'm not talking
about political stuff and topical stuff.
I'm really just sort of talking about
what are my thoughts and feelings on
myself or on the situation that I
just experienced. Like it's just,
you know,
I'm not getting into in depth in Paul,
what would something, I'm sure, but, um,
but what if something happened
and it was relevant to your life?
Like what if there were some new political
decision or some new local law or
whatever that is relevant to your life.
You might start talking about it
and saying, yeah, like, you know,
like what if you had a really good
friend and the friend was trying to get
married and they were gay,
and then all of a sudden the law passed
and you couldn't marry gay people
anymore,
couldn't get married.
You would say something
about that, right? Yeah.
That would upset me and I'm
sure I would talk about it
and then there'd be some guy
in the audience goes, fucking,
if I wanted to hear your fucking opinion,
I'd be a to you.
Yeah, I don't know. Then I
would just say like, thank
you, sir. Please sit back down.
Yeah.
So you're preparing your prepare yourself
for all these people to say shitty
things to you.
Yeah, I mean, I'm used to it. I
mean, like you said before, you know,
if you get it from your friends first,
when you get it from the outside world,
it's not so bad.
Yeah. Yeah. Our sphere is helping you,
but I have always admired
chicks doing comedy. It's,
it's more difficult than men
doing it I think. I think it's a,
it's a totally different
animal and it's like,
it's like women's mixed martial arts too.
You know,
like a lot of people don't like watching
women fight like Yo, much more crazy.
It is for a chick to be fighting.
That's like a dude fighting with swords.
You know, like men want to
fight, it fills, it's normal.
But for chicks to actually train
and fight and pick a girl, I'm like,
listen bitch,
at six weeks we're going to throw down.
You better fucking ready and then you
run it up pills and shit and throwing
sandbags around for a girl to actually
do that. That bitch has got to be crazy.
You know,
like off the deep end.
Crazy like 10 times crazier
than a man is doing it.
The,
they're tough cookies.
I once had lunch with this chicken knock
Amera she's like an undefeated champion
boxer and she like just,
they're tough.
That's where she's really hot. You wish
really, you would have went with it?
Probably she reigned over and just
grabbed the hairs on the back of your neck
and just ball them up and just
controlled your head. Just about,
my cat's trying to get in here, get out
here. You fuck. Would you let her happen?
Did that? I guess I
would. Yeah, you would.
And you would let her.
So you're down for a lesbian experiences.
Just the chick's got to pull the
trigger. Not the, I guess I, I mean,
I'm pretty easy going, so whatever
happens, you're pretty easy going.
There's no guys that ever say that.
What you're thinking about gay sex?
I'm pretty easy going. My family,
my family thinks I'm a lesbian.
Really? Yeah. Why is that?
Because you're not married with
a child already that well, no.
I think just my mom is when I went
through college and not, didn't date,
my mom's like, oh yeah,
maybe you're a lesbian.
I have a neighbor who has a
gay son for sure. Really? Yeah.
The kids like 10 now. Oh, and I've
been saying the kids gay forever.
Not that there's anything wrong with it,
but I mean I've been saying like, look,
there's this kid is gay and everyone's
like, you can't say that. You know,
he's around his mom all the time. His
Dad's always working. I'm on stop it.
Stop it.
The kid's gay
sometimes, you know? I mean in my opinion,
I think you're born gay and
it's like being a comedian.
This is actually important to me.
Like you're born a comedian and you
just figure it out as you go along.
Yeah.
I don't think you're born a comedian.
I think you're raised in a fucked up
way that makes you want a lot more
attention than a normal person gets and a,
it's to compensate from the
lack of attention that you
got when you were younger
and that's why I become a performer.
That's why everyone becomes a performer.
I think that's probably a more
intelligent way of looking at it.
Maybe not everyone,
I shouldn't say everyone cause some,
I've met some people that just got
into it and they had great childhoods.
I did. I had a great childhood I
think, and no one believes me. I did.
Doesn't sound like it from all the shit
you're saying. You were tortured. I mean,
I was tortured by everyone else,
but I'm really close with my mom and dad.
It doesn't have to be a mom and dad,
you know?
It could be just all the feelings of
alienation that you felt when you were
younger. Yeah, I think that's a good,
I always wonder like I have this crazy
theory that gets over talked about on
this show that the entire world, that
everything, all the events, car accidents,
you dropped the book, you
know, you move into the, the,
this lane in the parking lot.
Like all these things are all somehow
or another connected like some giant
fucking mathematical program and
that really shitty parents and shitty
situations growing up that like coming
out of those things, it's like the force,
the negative force of those things makes
the rebound like so much greater and it
makes the, the, the creativity so much
greater with a person that makes you know,
makes the to perform,
you know,
and the crazy ability to create something
special because the fact that you
desperately want this attention and then
all these people benefit from that and
like, you know, like people that go to
see it like wow, they had this great time.
Why they have a great time?
Well they had a great time
because somewhere along the
line this kid got fucked
with,
you know,
so that negative of that blossoms out and
becomes this performance and then it's
all somehow another balanced out.
That's pretty intense.
I mean it is. I mean look, that's where
sluts come from, right? Sluts come from,
they don't, they didn't get
enough attention. It's always
the same story, but guys,
look,
men,
it's very convenient that slots exist
because if every time you had sex you have
to be in some like fucking
serious relationship and
God, that's a lot of work.
You know like maybe sometimes I'm
confused. I don't know where I'm at.
And you just want to go around and
fuck around. Well you need slots man,
or a flashlight or a flashlights.
I liked the way you segway young lady.
You really know how to work this.
I see big things.
When are we expecting the
literal Esther podcasts?
You can start your own podcast
in the works. It's in the
works. Is it really? Yes,
it would be good. I think you'd be good
at that shit. Yeah. And you could, I can,
you can interview Unicorns and stuff.
Yeah,
it's a good way to develop material too.
So you're doing like three
minutes sets for the most part,
like five minutes on Sundays and Mondays.
And then like whenever I just searched
for bar shows and spots at the comedy
clubs. And so yeah, like I'd say
eight minutes. It's like a good,
what's the most time we've ever
done on stage? Um, like 20, 20.
That's like the weird, that's like when
it begins to get strange. Yes. Right.
Like you'll like God,
am I still up here?
I'm still talking like the transition
between like those little short sets and
like doing a real set,
you know it's definitely different and
especially too like I've gotten so used
to just having to prepare
three or five minutes.
So now it's like harder to be
like oh I have to keep going.
Yeah it's definitely how you use Twitter,
Twitter, a lot to write, don't you?
Cause I ever since I was like,
I guess in high school I used to carry
a notebook around with me and just
anything that like struck me as weird,
I would write it down.
And that's sort of like
how I've transitioned.
Like that's my Twitter page now and it
just so I can remember it because I want
to make it something later.
Twitter is great because it
gives you only 140 characters,
which makes it kind of an art form.
Like you have to edit.
And funny and usually that's good though.
I always find that I get too verbose.
There's too many words.
If I just,
you just leave me alone with
everything already got done. Blog.
And so 160,000 characters long.
I'll just keep going.
But really it should be a couple
sentences. You don't use extra words.
It helps comedy. That's like
a good comedy tool. Yes. Yeah.
140 characters is perfect. It's
not even a text message. You know?
You just gotta be safe. Be
able to say something funny,
really quick. It's just a,
it's a strange thing that we can connect
to each other like this. You know,
there's never been a time in human
history where it's so easy to get in touch
with human beings. You don't
need a magazine, you don't need a
new station. I mean, look at this. We're
just talking right now. We're, we're,
you know,
my fucking office and we're connected
and hundreds of thousands of people
download this. It's, it's very strange.
You're going to have a lot of new
people masturbating to you. Oh
yeah. No. Thousands right
now. There's guys with dig out
right now. You're so wrong.
Zero. Elster you're so exciting. Oh No.
You just became a hundred
times more exciting.
Why all the stories
you've told God damn girl.
Uh, does that freak you out? No. Do you
think you've ever posed for playboy? Um,
I actually interned for playboy in
college and that's not the same thing.
Um, I don't know where ever were
you ever thrown into the humanics?
The Hefner mixed? No. No. I was not.
I was not on that pretty side of
things. If you got famous, you know,
and you got an offer, do you think you
pose for playboy? Probably. I mean, what?
Hustler? No. No, not
too much in penthouse.
I don't know the difference
between all of them,
but I was a nude model and
different sheet. All of them.
Playboy playboys, impossible to jerk
off to. Right. Unless you're desperate.
If you're jerking off to play ball,
you might as well be jerking off the JC
Penney's catalog. Who are we kidding?
They're all impossible to jerk off to.
Now our brains, I've gone past photos. Uh,
you know,
not necessarily if you gotta do what you
gotta do really trapped in Alabama in a
hotel room, there's no internet
connection. Now there's a seven, 11,
and you just close your eyes.
Yeah.
Thinking about like my cousin
or something cause was kidding.
I said her dream weaver.
We'll have to end with that song.
Can you continue to download that song?
That's how we're going to
end the podcast back. Yeah,
but I like playing a song from the
70s yeah, I think it's cool. Yeah,
it's cool.
I like I said earlier,
like I have a thing for very
pretty put together ladies being
Mrs. Reagan had a really
interesting point.
She said that she thought it was funny
that playboy used to be like the girl
next door and penthouse was like
these really skanky whores. She goes,
but now it seems like Penn
houses like regular girls,
they look like more like
real girls and playboy.
It's like all these bleach blondes. It's
like the same look over and over again.
The Holly Madison type look, it's
like, it's a, an an manufactured look.
It's like that's become
the look of playboy.
And I think it happened when somebody
around, when Hugh Hefner stop fucking,
he just like, just like
fucking, you know what I mean?
It wasn't like what he was attracted
to. Yeah. There's like all of a sudden,
you know,
we used to be like the girl next door man.
But somehow on another girl next door is
not as attractive as it used to be to a
lot of people. A lot of people would
just rather have the whores, you know,
it's just like lit. I want big
stupid looking fake tits and dirty.
I want to know that you're
going to definitely take
it in the mouth right away.
You know? I don't want to have to talk
you into anything. You're a freak here.
Dirty Bitch. Professionally. They do
like that. Why? Because we're sad.
Sad little monkeys. Well, it's exciting.
It's exciting. It's exciting wars.
Yeah. Yeah. Cause you don't
get that. I don't know.
It seems because it's rare.
Yeah. Yeah. It is exciting.
And why are they doing it? They're doing
it because they've got a deficit, right?
Something. Yeah. The same thing that
the reason why people become comedians,
except usually there's abuse involved
in porn. Yeah. Almost always.
Every single one that I've ever really
sat down and talked to after a while,
you get to the heart of the matter.
There's something,
something happened that
shouldn't have happened.
Also,
to be a comedian,
I think you have to have a very
strong brain and be really,
I think you have to be really smart.
Yeah. Yeah. You can't, it's hard to,
you can't just be molested. No, no.
That would be nice. What
have you got? A good body.
You can have like a chimp
brain still do porn. There's,
there's a lot of open miker is that
when you watch them, you can totally go.
I don't think even if this guy did
it for 20 years, he will ever get it.
You'll ever be funny. Yeah,
so I think that that there's,
there's something to that.
You have to be definitely smarter or at
least at some level with something. Yeah.
There's a lot of people that they don't
understand what it really is. You know?
They don't know what the
fuck they're really doing.
I've had friends that do it that they
tried to do it and I've thought they'd be
able to do it and then they could never
figure out how to talk to an audience
like, like a, just like a bunch
of people, you know, they could,
they never figured out
how to and be themselves.
They never figured out how to tap into
it and they just were terrible where I
thought they were like Eddie Bravo was,
he bombed. Like he did it like nine times.
He bombed horribly, like six of those nine
times. He could never get it together.
But if you talked to him in person, he
was always funny. He would say funny shit.
Like, why? Why can't you go up
there and do that? Like what is it?
We will have an idea of like
being a standup comedian
and they don't realize you
just be yourself.
There's that.
And there's also some people when
they're forced to be on stage with that
spotlight on them and there's a bunch
of strangers who don't know them and you
know, you're demanding the
strangers attention and then you,
you really start to make, uh, like
an audit of your own thoughts. Like,
are these words, these shots, do these,
do I really need to be the guy in front
of the microphone or am I an idiot?
And you know,
those all,
any weird fucking insecurities
you have about who you are,
just come spilling out when you're trying
to get people to laugh and you have a
microphone and you're the one that gets
the mic and the light is on you and
shit. It's scary. I think
if you can accept that,
you're going to say things that people
won't laugh at and it's going to be a
year, it'll be okay. I think
a little more comfortable.
Yeah. But that's sucks.
Decks sucks hard to be up there.
And you be the one who's commanding
the attention and said, look at me,
look at me, look at me. And they're
like, okay, I'm looking what? Um,
okay, what else? Um, yeah,
there's something crazy that happened, you
know, hey, they can't think about it. Oh,
I know, right? Does that feel in a
tailspin feeling when you're bombing? Oh,
Ooh. And then you're driving home and
you're like, fuck, fuck. Oh my God,
I forgot about it for a second, then. Fuck
you remember it again? Shit. Fuck. Oh.
Have you ever led a heckler get to you?
Like having the heckler ever women
against one against, you know,
all hecklers or retards?
There's no genius. There's
no genius. Fucking brilliant,
awesome dude. I hecklers all
cunts. They're all dumb cons.
Don't understand what's
going on or where they are.
Like they're so stupid. Yeah,
well, you know, they're just,
they really wished they were up on stage.
They just don't have the balls or the
brains or whatever the fuck it is.
It's just our society has gotten used
to having its own input constantly.
And Youtube videos, let me
call my aunt. She's taught,
she's fucking talking nigger, nigger cunt.
I said that at a certain point in time.
I wanted to get to, I want to, um,
get to a point where every video that I
have that's on Youtube to somebody just
writes nigger cunt in the comments just
because he can and no one can stop you.
You know,
it's like,
it's because you can and your
name is luck shod nine, six,
four. You know, you could just,
who are you? You're nothing.
You're just have voice out
there screaming into the abyss.
Do you think there's ever going to become
a part point that like we are all like
having to be like social
security numbers on the Internet.
Meaning you cannot no longer Joe Rogan
for you are going to be your social
security number and like they're
going to take it that way.
Cause I think that's social security Gump
number. No, because if that's the case,
then people will be able to get your
information. I mean, not, not, not,
not actually. Just having a number like
this. So she took your fucking name,
you cowards, you know what's your name?
Is Your name? Bob Smith will peep.
Fucking Bob Smith. You Pussy. I'm Joe
Rogan. Why do you gotta hide? Well,
I love, you know, I don't want the
people at work to know what I'm doing.
Well then you know what this,
that's a legitimate point actually not
making fun of a legitimate point for a
lot of people.
You know,
you know we were reading about
this the other day that the um,
the number of people that get drug
tested on the job, random drug tests.
It's like 40%. You walking
tests and set. Yeah,
I'd make sure you smoke pot if you know
it's still testing on smoking weed.
I don't why you editing those
videos from them. Trust me, I don't,
I don't really test Ya. What I do is
just, I'll just collect your urine.
So like a hobby of mine.
I showed her that Megan icicles out of it.
Tell me about drinking your own.
Well, you could just drink it.
You can drink your own. Does it
really do anything? I don't know.
I mean you take vitamins once.
Do you know if it's good for you?
I mean you got to read a
lot of peer reviewed papers
on the effects of vitamins.
Then you have two objectives.
We analyze your own performance
and you have to think, okay,
was I working extra hard during that time?
Does that maybe why I feel better?
I was like, was I watching
what I eat? You know,
to really be sure that a
vitamin is benefiting you,
you've got to have a lot of thinking
about it and you have taken over a long
time and then not take it. So I dunno,
I only drank my piss a few times.
Doesn't taste that bad.
Would you ever drinks really in the back
of your head was like super healthy?
Yeah. What'd you drink? So you,
which maybe tasted if we get some PR,
you know Google searches,
well there's a lot in,
you can't Google search because
there's a lot of nutty websites.
They want you wearing crystals white.
You took your
fucking recycling, your,
your, your sperm as well.
I noticed every time I type in symptoms
and to Google, I always like, oh,
you have aids, you have Crohn's disease.
Oh, when you tap into your own stuff,
like if it's just like runny nose,
back pain, you have aids, you know,
you end up at some message board.
It's like you should
just throw this symptoms into iTunes
and download Elton John Songs instead.
There's a recent study that suggests
that all cancer is man created,
that cancer did not exist until human
beings started fucking around with
chemicals and polluting the
environment and eating things.
They're not supposed to be eating and
eating processed foods and an unnatural
diet and that in the natural form,
if people just ate plants
and animals and you know,
and hunted and fished and there was no
pollution in the water and we lived like
a nomadic hunter gatherer existence.
No cancer.
Yes, I, that's a spirit man. I agree
with. I've always thought that that's,
so what does a history
of breast cancer then?
Is that just a history of being
susceptible to pollution? Yeah,
I mean radiation, all who know? I
don't know the twist and sucked.
I don't think that's, how
do you know? As I said,
I don't think that breaks down DNA.
You know,
like you're doing this constantly
and breaks down the DNA
bay.
It's like the Lance Armstrong analogy.
The reason why I want to use the last
one of those balls because it's always
rubbing up against that seat. The ball
just get tired of it. It makes sense.
That ball just tap the fuck out.
You never know. I mean, but some of
it they say is genetic too. I thought
I'm going to get Tonkin. Yeah, well that's
what I don't understand. Is it genetic?
If is cancer people,
it's genetic that people get cancer.
Is it a in if they haven't proven
which they have not proven.
This is a theory that
all cancer is manmade.
I'm sure there has to be a bunch of
people that don't believe in it that also
feel just as strongly. But
if, if it is all man made,
then all that a genetic predisposition
is you're more susceptible to whatever
these toxins are that's creating
this ailment in your body.
Um, right. Yeah. I, I don't know. It's,
it's hard because yeah.
What can you have a genetic
predisposition to have cancer?
Yeah. I mean, if,
well not if what these people are
saying is that all cancer is because of
pollution and chemicals and shit.
You're not supposed to have in
your body in the first place.
Stuff that didn't exist in nature until
man started tampering with nature.
If they're right, then no, you're just
more susceptible to all this bullshit.
Right. I mean, what's,
what actually kind of boggles my mind is
that I can eat peanuts and someone else
will eat a peanut and die.
Yeah. Cause it's so weird. Yeah.
And we have the same body.
We all have long. Yeah.
And whatever.
Right.
Well that's when the autism argument
gets really trippy when you start talking
about vaccinations, you know, and people
go, well, vaccinations can't cause autism.
They don't cause problems with kids.
They don't do anything.
You can't even get a kid peanut butter.
You're not supposed to
give a kid peanut butter,
but it's okay to shoot all these chemicals
and these live viruses in the child.
You're sure every child is going to be
cool with mint, not necessarily. Right.
You know,
and then of course they're going to
have every scientific study possible.
They will highlight the fact that,
you know,
there is no connection between
this and that and that and this.
But when you research it, you find out
that they're the, uh, um, um, uh, vaccine.
Courts in this country have given out
thousands of different awards to families
because of brain damage
caused by vaccines. Oh my God.
Thousands of different kids.
I mean, it's not just one,
and this is what they've awarded
money too. So it's not a great,
it's on a black and white
area. It's fucking, it's tricky.
Different people's bodies respond
differently to all sorts of things.
That's why I never tell people smoke pot,
drink beer,
do this because some people can't.
Some people just drink one
beer and all of a sudden they,
the switch goes off in their head and
they're fucked and gone. It's not mean.
It's probably not you.
But for some people they have some
weird biochemical setup and you know,
it makes them more susceptible to cancer.
You know,
it makes them more susceptible to this,
makes them more susceptible to that.
And that's just like a tomato. Like if
you don't know you're allergic tomatoes,
you eat a tomato, now, Bam,
you're dead. But my friend's wife,
her whole life has had problems
with wheat and she didn't know it.
She didn't know she had
an allergy to wheat.
So she had all these health ailments,
didn't know what it was,
didn't know what she had fatigue. She'd
get headaches, all these different things.
Cut Out. Wheat gone. It's
nuts, man. I fear I haven't,
I feel like I have something like
that, you know, like, yeah, totally.
Because there's some times where it just
seems like I'm allergic to something.
I should really get it tested out.
But then it goes away. You know,
like guessing checking. It's really
annoying to deal with your problem, Brian,
is you're still smoking
cigarettes. I mean beef, you know,
when I wasn't smoking cigarettes,
you know, and you weren't smoking,
you were only not smoking for like a year.
So your body was probably trying
to recover from the factory.
We're smoking constantly for your whole
life. I mean when you say when you,
I'm not smoking the majority of
your life you've been smoking.
So even you saying when I'm not smoking,
you're not the in the peak of health
going and fucking drinking weaker at shoes
or Greg, we've got good weird Greg
through thought guy. You know,
I mean health is such a tricky thing. As
I've gotten older, like I'm sitting here,
my back fucked up or hurt my back last
night and Jujitsu it's not fuck that was
just some sort of a muscle pull.
But as you get older,
like for sure I recognize the differences
in good and bad behavior and the like,
you can still have a good body and keep
your body healthy and have all this
energy, but you have to be way more
diligent than when you're younger.
You have to really make sure
that if I eat like shitty food,
if I go out and have a big fat,
stupid cheeseburger and ice cream
Sundae and I will fucking wall is a good
motivator. Like that hurts later
sort of. It's not that it hurts,
I just feel like a lard ass. I feel
like I got hit with a tranquilizer dart.
That's why like I'm up fucking bear at
the circus that ran a muck and proud
fired fucking Darta
normally just lay in it.
I don't want to hang over. You see
people dealing with hangovers. I'm like,
what's that?
Goddamn cheeseburgers are awesome.
You know I went to five guys for the
first time the other day. Yeah. Yeah.
Not as good as in and out.
Not as many choices and no shakes.
I haven't been to the counter. The counter
is that another one? That's a good one.
And so it's still pretty fucking awesome.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean if I'm looking for something to
eat and it's right there, I'm going in,
but the lack of shakes,
it's really disappointing.
It's weird how the hamburger places in La,
I don't think it's,
it's spread out out of la too much,
but like how there's all these now
trendy burger places now in La.
Have you noticed this? That flood out
of nowhere you oh no. The poor thing out
your habit is another one.
There's the one cup of Colab in there.
I've been to those. Those are pretty
decent. Yeah, it was a decent,
weird how that just came out of burgers
or on the burgers are delicious and
Americans love murdered meat.
Yeah,
we love it.
We love getting somebody else to do all
the dirty work and packaging it in a
nice circle. Nice flat circle.
Cook it up, give it to me.
I don't want to have to do anything.
I don't want to go out and fucking grow
grass and then have the cow eat the
grass. Then shoot the cow on the head and
hanging up by its ankles and gut it and
process it and chop it up and grind it
down and then press it and then cook it
and just give me a burger. Right.
Okay. And Burger King and Mcdonald's.
Who knows when that fucker
was actually cooked.
I mean those things are just sitting
in a bin and they flip it onto a pad,
throw it in the microwave.
I had McDonald's the other day and it's
weird how you actually don't even think
about it when you're eating it that,
hey,
this is actually really
supposed to be like a hamburger.
It's not supposed to be like I Mcdonald's.
You know? It's like different tastes.
Right? It's like I always get the
two double cheeseburger meal. Yeah,
there's like hamburger cookies.
That's hilarious. But yeah,
you don't really think of it like, wow,
this is like really good cow. You know?
This is a good hamburger.
No, it's, there's a website
online where a dude has a,
he's running a running tally.
I don't know if it's legit,
but I think you said it's
like 180 days so far.
He kept a happy meal and it hasn't rotted
yet. Was dried out sitting there. Yeah.
He's got all these photos of it.
It was on the board was on the road and
boy thing ever seen that and he's got a
photo of it at 180 days and
it looks like perfect today.
Preservatives are really scary.
You know,
what the fuck is that doing to your body?
Ooh.
Some stuff that keeps things from growing
on it that's not good to have in your
body when your body consists of a bunch
of different positive organisms that are
helping you,
you know all these different bacteria
that you need like acidophilus and
probiotics and what is
happening when you're eating.
They're going to war or those
preservatives going to war with the,
the good bacteria in your body.
Dead bodies were just decomposing
a lot slower than they used to.
I don't know really. Yeah.
That's interesting. It
sounds like some pita talk.
This is what I've heard,
man.
I don't give a fuck how quick I
rot the end of all the whole thing.
When you die in your hair,
still still growth. Is that
true though? Oh, I hope not.
I heard it was maybe a little
bit because it's growing, right?
I mean to think like what it was already
going to grow kind of pops out like a
little
cycle to it. Hm. I Dunno.
There's a crazy story I watch
on HBO once where they had that.
Do you remember that guy, Dr Baton?
He was a the autopsy guy. I believe.
That's his name. Doctor
Badden, HBO, real autopsy.
I forget what the name
of the show. Well, one,
one of the most fascinating ones was
this one guy. His wife died. Okay.
And he kept preserving
her and like he was,
I dunno if he worked at a
home or whatever the fuck
he did,
but he somehow or another kind of embalmed
her body and created like a little
fleshlight little plastic teeth.
Okay. No, it wasn't his wife.
That's why it was so creepy.
It was one of his patients and he fell
in love with their pa some somehow or
another, he got this woman's,
I believe it's a patient.
I'm fucking this whole story up now,
the bottom line is this dude had a corpse
in his house that he kept preserved
and he would cover it with like gallons
and gallons of perfume and he designed
like a little plastic vagina. It
would fuck this plastic vagina. Yeah.
And he stole the body from the grave yard,
like you went into the grave,
brought it into his house and was
like covering it with perfume.
I had bought crates of perfume.
[inaudible] blotting. Yeah.
This rotting fucking hunk of meat that
used to be this woman and he's sticking
his dick and like this little garden
hose that he's created for her vagina.
I to try it once. Try once.
And people, a lot of Tequila.
A lot of people do freaky
things to dead Bot.
It's just like something to them like
desiccating a corpse is like a huge crime.
You know, like people that's
like, it's offensive to society.
It's like for a lot of people
it's like the ultimate taboo.
Like dig somebody up in their head.
Look, look at me. I'm a retard.
I got these fake skulls everywhere.
All around. Like what is
different though? Yeah,
but what is this fascination like what
is the fascination with skulls and shit?
Like this is a real one actually.
It's totally real.
Oh my God, she's retarded.
Additional. It's anything real.
It's got tribal over its head. Could. Yes.
If you were a Maori living in nosy,
are you really?
If someone's going to tell me something,
why? Why are they lying? I don't know.
Right.
Cause you wouldn't lie.
So it's good for you to be around
a bunch of scumbags. It's good.
I have to be pretty careful.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful to carry
a knife to the comedy store.
How'd you become friends
with Brian on his show?
He's on my video and thought it was funny.
And then what did he do?
Did he bust a move? What did he do?
You can tell and I can't remember.
I came up the year, I was like, I just
went to the, no, wait, where did he say,
can I be your stalker? Oh
God, Brian. No, I said,
your video was cool.
And then I said I'm going to be stalker.
And then every time I walked by it I
think I was like, you're so awesome.
Or something like that. Don't like
that. Wow. Really smooth pickup movies.
Pickup. Well, it's worked.
We've successfully made a lot of videos.
They get pretty awesome.
You guys just killed the shit out of
this conversation. Fucking faggotry
so what is gay?
Yeah, you can't say that right?
How? How sensitive are you to that?
Like the idea that there's certain things
that are offensive to talk about and,
and, and expressions. Like you
can't say gay, like that's gay,
like that really bothers
a lot of people. Um, it's
hard. I mean sometimes I say oh and bumps
friends, you'll say that's gay, right?
Not really. I've tried to police myself
on it a little bit, but it's definitely,
I know, I know that it's not
rooted in some sort of evil hatred.
I love gay people. I, like I said, I
probably am gay, so it's hard for me.
I don't know. I, but it's tricky, right?
Sometimes people say it and
they don't mean it. I mean,
I say faggot all the time and I do too.
Yeah.
Sometimes people get mad
at me and they'll say like,
you know what you're saying is
hateful, this done? I'm like, no.
So I want to meet are not hateful
mean like feelings or hateful. Right.
Intent is hateful. Yeah. But if
you were thinking about, you know,
you are the type of person who is
ostracized as a child and all these pretty
constantly kept you on the outside.
What if that was a word that
they use all the time for you?
What if you actually were gay and you
were gay at a young age and you know,
it was like,
look at her that fucking gay loser and
then you're around people and they're
like, that's gay, that's
gay. I'm like, Shit, I'm gay.
And you're saying this movie is
gay? What the fuck, man? Yes sir.
Suck. But I think you can't give
words that much power. And if you do,
it's not, it's not smart. I don't know.
But is that easy to say because you're on
the outside of it maybe. Yeah, probably.
I think about that sometimes, but other
than that, I think stop it. Faggot.
Fucking get over it.
It's a big deal.
Yeah. I mean some, I dunno, I,
I really think that if
you're not racist really,
and if you're not hateful of gay people,
really then say what you want.
I mean, there's certain things that are
fucking gay men blow drying their hair.
Always gay. You don't want to
dry your hair naturally. Well,
you want to accelerate the drying process,
right? Fuck. Like who? Your pace mass.
Those are gates. So gay, they even call
them facials, but yet all it is is like,
hey man, you like to open your pores. You
don't have your face doesn't break out.
You're gay. You know, but
it's real though. You're
going to be like, that's gay.
If you have bad skin,
you want to clear your skin up.
I think you should get a lot of you came
over to my house and had a face mask on
with like blue he back. Well we believe
that they do face mask, brow face mask.
What you were before you go to
bed or American psycho. Yes.
Do you ever read that book is all about
facials and masks and fucking so he
wasn't gay.
He was crazy scary.
It's like a red bull and are not read
well cranberry and vodka cranberry and
vodka is,
you know like the second you throw
triple sec into that shit that's caught a
cosmo and if you can't drink
a cosmo that's fucking gay,
but yet it's just a splash of triple sec.
I like girly drinks.
I try to white Russians. I like
white Russians. That's kind of girly.
I like 'em Pina coladas and shit
stuff with it's, I don't get it.
People think that they're so
refined that they like these.
It's just like you want it to
taste like candy sometimes,
but sometimes you don't. I
like Jack Daniels to sometimes
I like a beer, you know,
like a Sam Adams in a shot of Jack
Daniels that's like, that's to ass tastes,
you know? So it's not candy at
all, but it's weird. How are you?
The older you get you start liking
things like, like I never liked blue,
but then around 24
I'm like, oh, blue cheese is awesome.
You know? And like we have these things,
you have these things
just like that though.
Like I never used to like pickles and
now I'm fucking addicted to pickles all
lives I still don't like yet. Blue Cheese
is tricky because it's mold. Yeah, right.
You know we, when we were cheeses
boulder. Yeah, right. A lot of cheeses.
When we were on fear factor,
we used a lot of expensive cheese
for the stunts because some of them,
there was a,
there's a cheese shop in Beverly hills
that has like really authentic French
cheeses and all these different
European cheeses that are like really,
really strong.
Like their smell is horrendous and somehow
none of these freaky fucks in Europe.
They, they get into this stuff and they
would bring it out to the set and that we
would open up the tubs and make everybody
smell out and they'd be like vomiting,
like literally people be dry heaving
and this is some shit that was really
expensive and now it is just a funky,
powerful cheese. And we would throw that,
that was like a secret ingredient that
we would throw into a lot of the blended
shit that people had to
eat that smelled horrific.
The reason why it smelled Baz worms don't
really smell that bad when you grind
them up and have to throw
that funky fucking shit
cheese and that's what made it
smell better. Yeah. Worms.
The smell like worms,
especially because they're fresh worms.
Well they're for,
it smells like dirt kind of because
they're really, that's all they are.
They're like tissue and dirt.
You're drinking dirt, you know,
but the worms that we're,
we're getting,
we're getting these worms come from
dirt farm so they know what the fucking
worms are eating. It's all, you get
them out of the fish supply shop.
So been really eating worms is not,
not big a deal.
The big deal was this fucking cheat.
Then this cheese is expensive and people
are like, did you get that from ODG?
D is,
Oh this is Smith is one to buy his
bid to flow for whatever reason,
people just got into those
fucking creepy smells.
I recently found out that I am a video
game tran, transsexual, video game,
transsexuals. Anytime I, I'd never even
thought about that. You play as a girl?
Yeah,
I always plays a girl at like,
I just got this new game called fallout
new Vegas where it's like you're, you're,
you're looking at an ass the whole time
you're running around the whole game and
it's going to take you months to
beat this game. And I'm thinking,
I don't want to look at a man's ass. I'm
gonna pick a girl character, you know?
So I, I write and I think back, I've
always like Tony Hawk, you know,
any kind of video on Microsoft, Laura,
I'm always playing girl characters.
I always pick girl characters.
I've been sucks though,
is the guys end up hitting on you thinking
that you're a girl and so that then
it makes you even feel more gay. Well,
how often do you hit on them back?
Do you walk around and pretend
that you're a girl? Yeah.
Especially if I don't have a microphone.
I'll just like turn around a couple
times, you know, shake it a little. Yeah,
that's a big thing right now. See,
I'm out of the loop video games,
but a lot of people are
talking and they're online.
They're talking on microphones, right?
Well nowadays, yeah, usually and shit.
That would be annoying, man. I don't
want to hear all these little nuggets.
It's weird because video games, if
you ever thought, you know what,
I don't think people are racist against
black people and that much anymore.
Second, you go online, bullshit.
All, all, all the rules are out.
It's just nonstop racism.
It's just like message boards.
It's same thing except they don't have
to worry about their account being good
for six months a year and keep talking
on the message board. Right. You figured
this is the one game want to see you,
you nigger cunt.
It's really weird though
when you're playing a video
game and it's usually like,
you know,
like one other person and it's just
like an 11 year old kid and you're like,
so hey, how old are you? And you're like,
you're like, oh hey. That's great. Uh, so,
uh, we should go over here
and get the sword. Oh, okay.
I feel like you seem very strong.
Video Games are like 11 year olds and
like 37 year old. No, no, no. There's
people that are playing video games all
day. Video Games are addictive as fuck.
They're awesome. That's the problem.
There's so much fun to play there.
So God damn addicted. I need to
find one though. I would like,
it's a weird thing to me.
It's a weird thing to me that we have
like this level of connectivity with like
Twitter and Facebook and and and you know,
message boards and stuff like that.
We have this crazy level of connectivity
where we're way more immersed in each
other's lives than we've ever been before.
But yet it's easier to be anonymous
and to be country with people.
It's easier to like say
shitty things cause you're
not saying it in front of him.
You don't have to deal with the social
consequences of looking him in the eye
and insulting them. You just, you fucking
shit and they can just do it. It's,
that's a weird thing. It's like we're
more immersed but we're more disconnected.
It's like, and we're slowly becoming
more and more used to, you know,
being able to be shitty to people with no
repercussions and not worried about it.
And being able to take out all your own
personal bullshit on some just random
stranger online and attack them and try
to break them down. And you really, like,
you're going about your
day and total silence,
like you're sitting in front of
Kiva, click, click, click, click,
click saying the meanest,
nastiest, most harsh shit than me.
While there's no sound coming out
and you're walking around your house,
you're pouring yourself coffee and you
going back to the message board and
typing some more horrible
evil shit. And you know, it's,
it's a very strange thing that,
you know,
it used to be all our interactions that
we had, the ones that were designed for,
or we look at each other and then all
of a sudden someone invented a phone as
well, now you're interacting with
somebody who can't see anymore,
and then all of a sudden the person
becomes faceless and now they're on a
message board and now you're
just a name and like, whoa. Yeah.
And your Avatar is buckwheat,
you know, it's like, okay,
who is this guy's got buckwheat
from for the rascals as this photo.
I don't even know who the fuck he is. They
tell me that I'm ugly and yes, exactly.
Dude. So many people have been
exposed from my message board,
like so many people that
were like really super conti,
but they fucked up and
somewhere along the line,
one of the Internet sleuths figured out
who they were and then through their
photos up and all their Facebook
photos and then you get to see, oh,
you're a douchebag, right?
Oh, here you are. I mean,
how many times that happened on the
Rogan board? Oh, totally. All the time.
Oh my God.
We had this one guy who was an asshole.
He was so mean to everybody like on,
and he couldn't tell him to stop doing it.
Like at a certain point in time
it was like, fuck dude, you know,
stop being a Douche bag and a contrarian.
Every time I fucking argument comes up,
you're insulting people and saying, we
found out he was like 700 pounds. Okay.
And he had would post on this weight
loss forum and he got his stomach fixed.
He was a staple
or,
yeah,
it was always like super
critical of anybody who did
anything to their boat. You,
you don't have the heart and the willpower
to do it on your own. You've all,
he says, fat fuck living in
his own shit is on apartments.
Where is why he's such an asshole
because his life sucked and then it was
exposed and flop.
Oh,
found that guy and just posted all of
his photos and all of his testimonials
about it. It was a totally different
person on this site, on our side,
which is a mean nasty asshole
on that website. He was all
about like, it was like,
you know, positive like Oprah stuff. Yeah.
Like he was on Oprah. He was like, well,
just trying to get used to the Diet.
Lol.
Yeah.
I mean you,
you learn a lot about a person's
character when they're anonymous. Totally.
You know, you get to know, I mean,
one of the things I found about my
message board is there's like three plus
million posts on it now.
I mean,
it's been around since like 1998 there's
thousands and thousands of members and
every day there's
thousands of posts and you,
you really can get to know someone
just by reading their words. You know,
you really can,
because weird situations will come up.
We'll someone will say something,
you can take it one way,
you can take it another way. You can
be upset, you could be insulting.
You could be,
you know,
you could listen to their criticism
and agree with it and you know,
have an own your own introspective
and objective viewpoint.
But people are so attached even to these
little anonymous fake names that you
know, you criticize their
anonymous fake screen name in,
that shit hits personal and then they
go after you and then they go after each
other. And I see these flame wars
like back and forth. I'm like,
how much of this would really happen if
you guys were standing in front of each
other? None of it, right?
I think they have those awkward meetings
of like the people from the Internet
and then no one says anything.
We've done that a bunch,
which we were doing that in
the 90s on my message board.
The first one was like evil and circle
jerk or the Houston circle jerk,
I think it was nine,
nine, nine, nine or 2000.
We were doing it like before I was
on fear factor. We would have these,
these message board meetings
where people would, you know,
come from the message board and we would,
we'd all be in Houston or whatever and
we'd all go out to dinner together and
you got to meet the creeps too.
There was like a few guys that
we were hanging out with. Like,
now I know why he's such a shit head.
Like you meet the guy in real life,
it's like fucking shifty and weird and
looks like you'd Roofie your drinks and
you know, there's, there's
always a guy that you meet.
Like we went to a strip club with one
guy from the message board and uh, uh,
one of the strippers came over and
put her hands on them, just like,
would you like to dance? Don't touch
me whore. And we're like, Whoa,
don't touch me whore.
And she went over and told the bouncer
and the bouncer came over to him and he
looked at me like I was going to say,
I'm like, dude, go get away. You're done.
You're done son.
You're a fucking creep will touch me.
Whore people are really hurt. And uh,
but you know, it's on all of them.
I mean it's like he didn't come off
that way online, which is strange.
He would say mean nasty shit.
But like normal,
like everybody else would say mean nasty
shit. It's like kind of commonplace.
He never like saw that, um, you
know that in his online thing,
he just seemed kind of
annoying. And then, you know,
you see him in La in real life, you're
like, oh, you're a fuck you're a mess.
You know, you never know. And then
there's people that won't even meet us,
which is like a whole new thing,
you know.
Flaco he is this guy named Flaco and he,
I won't even come meet us.
I don't know why. Well cause he
doesn't cause he attacks everybody.
He doesn't want you finding out what's,
what's really wrong. He knows we love him.
Yeah. Well not call, I had mad balls.
We got this guy named [inaudible]
who is a on our website.
He's been on my websites. It's
like the, I like 2000 or something.
Maybe not for that. Maybe even
before that. Yeah. And uh,
we were doing a show in San Francisco
and somehow or another came up,
we were talking to him, it was like five
years ago. More, more than five years ago.
So I said, you want to come
out to San Francisco, man,
I'll fly out. So he's like,
okay. Like he went with it and he
goes like this troll online. Yeah.
Likely fucking with people.
And like nine 11 happened and he was like,
two hours later, he's already,
you know, too early, too soon.
He's ruthless.
Like fucking with people and stuff.
But we hung out with them
and he was a nice guy. He was
nice when we hung out. We,
I gave him a pot lollipop. He
could handle it. He threw it up,
threw up in the street.
God, I forgot about that.
Pot lollipops are very powerful.
If someone tries to give you pot like
edible pot, don't do it. Don't do it.
Runaway, do not do it well. They'll
say like, oh, it's just a little bit,
you need to be an experienced pot smoker
before you start fucking around with
edibles and last,
you know that like this is your very
best friend and your friend made these
brownies and she told you, listen, there's
you just, if you take a quarter of this,
you're going to be fine,
but that's it.
Just a quarter and we're
not going anywhere anyway.
We're just going to sit on the couch
and watch TV and it'll be weird,
but you're going to be okay. And you
go, okay, I trust you, let's do this.
But if you're just like hanging out at
a party or something and someone says,
Hey, you want to pop cookie? No,
you did not want a pug times.
People at the comedy store, I've
been like, eat this pot Brownie.
You've never tried. So
irresponsible. God, thank God I'm,
those are fucking freaky.
The fuck out.
We were talking on the last podcast about
I got to high on a flight and I hit a
pot cookie and um,
some dude fart on Melanie
Griffiths head long story,
but I got so high,
get so high that I almost peed myself.
I literally thought about doing it.
Eating pot is way more strong
than smoking it a hundred times.
Not really like five times more powerful.
It's like you, you get way too high.
Way Too quick visual on top of it.
Yeah.
We did some more happy
and mellow like you know,
muscle relaxer type kind of
body buzz that's more visual.
It's going to fuck with your visuals
and everything. Can you close your eyes?
You see cartoons fucking see like
cartoons moving around and changing shape.
Like I saw all these looked like they
looked like 1960 Spiderman comic books,
like that style of drawing.
But it was all like
animals that didn't exist.
It was all like an, and they
were constantly changing
like every, every second,
every half a second. It was a new animal
and they were animals that didn't exist.
All drawn like Jack Kirby style.
You know,
like early marvel comics and they were
just moving and they were like all two
inches long and the entire sky was
filled with them. Wow. That's on us.
I just close my eyes and watch
that for like an hour lucky. So we,
I can't even freaking out though.
Couldn't, it was too high to enjoy it.
I can't even imagine. It's kind of
like dreams. You know how dreams,
yeah. It's like, it's like that,
but you're in railroad eating pause
is really too introspective too.
It makes you like really start
thinking about your life.
Like I broke down my whole childhood.
I'd, I started thinking about my eating.
You start really like considering all of
your behavior and the way you interact
with people and all the things you've
done wrong and all the things you would
love to take back. And you know,
it's just, it's really just fucking,
it's a mind fuck because it's another,
it's another chemical.
It's another chemical. When you eat
it, you should know that this is your,
your liver produces a chemical
called, uh, 11 hydroxy metabolite.
That's what it is. And it's only
when you eat pot, you don't,
it's not active in psychoactive
doses when you smoke it.
So it's literally different than
being stoned when you're smoking it.
Very dangerous. So don't let those
assholes just give you a pot Brownie.
That's Douchey, Douchey, a little
girl, he just popped Brownie.
You're the quarter curled up in the
fetal position in the puddle of pis
cause there's no way to make
it stop. No, there's no way.
No way you can try coffee,
but that doesn't work.
You just get like hyper and
high at the same time. You know,
you're still nervous and freaked
out and they're still be paranoid.
I remember once I was a bad acid trip
and for some reason I always thought that
drinking a bunch of milk was
supposed to do something.
So I remember sitting there fucking
sweating my ass off. Panicking,
just chugging milk. I remember I
might've done a whole thing of milk,
but then there's something where
your body just starts rejecting milk.
I just start puking milk everywhere a
chirping and I just remember the next day
I forgot I had done it and I just went
into the kitchen and it's just milk all
over the floor. Were you living
at home where you live? It alone.
I was living alone and a
little one bedroom would suck.
If you had explain this shit to your mom,
why is there milking
cheerios all over the floor?
Uh,
I didn't realize that um,
like lactose had a real effect on you.
I never really paid attention to it
until I started drinking raw milk.
Raw Milk is just milk that hasn't been
homogenized or pasteurized and you can
get it at like whole food stores.
I don't know if they have it anymore.
They might again stop kicking against
milk completely though. Right? Why?
Because it probably what you're about to
say. Well the raw with raw milk, it's,
it's dangerous where you don't
want to let it go too long.
You don't want to like keep
it around like you can't,
like you get a court and a milk,
you like,
you get a carton of milk and you
look at the expired expiration date.
It's like a month. How the fuck is
this gonna stay good for a month?
It's because everything worthwhile
has been barbecued out of it.
I mean there's still protein in it
and sort of still calcium in it,
but for the most part,
all the enzymes,
all the things that allow you to
digest it correctly, they're all gone.
But when you get raw milk,
you get everything in it and it's
really easy to adjust. It's like,
it feels totally different. Like it feels
different in your body. Gross though. No,
it tastes good, man. I was
drinking raw chocolate milk,
but I think they stopped carrying
it because I think it's dangerous.
Wholefoods used to be like,
these take chances,
but then they found out that Kombucha,
like this stuff that, I love this stuff.
I'm a big fan of probiotics
is very important.
Like probiotics are fucking huge for
your health. So I take acidophilus and I,
I drank probiotic drinks like this
Kombucha Shit, but apparently it's,
and some of them, if it sits
too long, it ferments too long.
Then it becomes more than
one half of 1% alcohol.
So then whole foods like pulled them
out. All of their stores. Are they back?
I will. They have some Kombucha,
but do they have the GTS Kombucha?
That's like the real shit.
That's the real shit.
Like you get chunks of the
mushroom in it or the fungus,
like someone shot loads in your drink.
You don't get that out of the week.
Kombucha,
the wheat Kombucha is just have it
out of the tap now in whole foods.
Yeah, that's stuff that they're
growing. They're making it. That's weak.
You know this company Gts, that was may.
Again, that's, that shit is powerful.
That's the kids.
I haven't gotten sick in over a year.
I would get sick constantly
because I'm always traveling,
traveling and shaking people's hands and
you're going on the road and you're in
planes and you're,
you know,
all that common in contact with
all these different germs and bugs.
Like for a long time,
like every couple months I'd get a cold
for the longest time because all the
traveling with this stuff,
never, I don't get sick, I don't,
I don't get sick and I'm always
getting like four hours sleep.
Then I take a flight,
I get tired like normal and everything,
but I'm not getting sick anymore.
And Ajay huge chunk of that is this stuff.
And acidophilus acidophilus milk culture.
So it's a bacteria that originates from,
yeah,
you keep it in the refrigerator and uh,
it's a live bacteria to healthy bacteria,
but it's a very aggressive, healthy
bacteria. When you eat acidophilus,
all this negative stuff that you come
in contact with when you're like, you,
you touched someone's hands and
they'll get like a cold or a sickness.
You're acidophilus attacks,
all that shit.
It's like having warriors in
your body to fight off bad germs.
And since you don't usually eat yogurt
because you don't like milks, uh,
you should really look into
it. Probiotic supplement. Yeah,
the Kombucha is a great one. It's a
great, I'll see them supplement though,
because I noticed your nails always
have like the, the calcium lack. Zinc.
What's wrong with your nails?
What do you fucking Weirdo.
You know what's wrong with her neck? Cause
I take a lot of pictures of her hands.
The hand model? Yeah.
You're a hand model. Yeah.
I was an American girl magazine catalog.
Your hands are tiny.
They're so small. It's like
where's the rest of the, her feet?
Her feet are smarter than wow.
Those are those.
My daughter Lola is feet might be a
little bigger than yours. She's too.
Let me take my shoes off.
She did go on the playground.
That's hilarious. Yeah. I didn't see you
guys look like you're in the same grade.
We have the same Halloween. How did we
get on this hands and feet thing? Uh,
because it's Kirk calendar. What
point? Yeah. How the hell do you know?
Because I thought that was cows. When
you have the white lines on your nails,
that's kind of a lack of calcium.
Has that started when I went vegan.
So there is downs. Whoa. Really?
Yeah. There's also, yeah,
you should totally take a some
kind of calcium via, you know,
I don't supplement calcium.
I think it's, yeah,
but you're supposed to have a certain
amount of calcium. Oh, I get calcium.
Broccoli as marketers. The
lines. Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
You don't eat broccoli. Yes,
I do.
To you like crazy Broccoli as how much
house you and then what then I think it
had, I don't, I'm not going to say, but
I think it does. It has a lot of calcium,
so a lot of protein to
broccoli as protein. That's
why gorillas love Broccoli.
If you go to the zoo, they throw gorillas
and chimps always turned on Broccoli.
They're really want to eat monkeys,
but they don't let them. Yeah,
I think that's so fucked up. They don't
let animals in the zoo kill things.
At the very least,
they should be allowing them to do what
they're naturally put on this planet to
do.
You know when you're sliding a cold tray
of meat into a cage and a lion looks at
that meeting, he was like, what the
fuck, man? Let me tell you some shit.
Can Be killed. Some shits on
it. Get some of that. Is it sad?
Yeah. Do you, are you an
animal rights person? Um,
I'm not out there doing anything for it,
but I believe in it and I,
I like the people that are,
I appreciate them.
The only problem with that is
if you don't kill some of them,
then they will overpopulate.
Let's say if we stopped killing cows and
stop killing chickens and stop killing
deer. If we were really did that, we
have a real issue. Is that really true?
I'm sure. Of course. Well,
it's definitely true with dear.
One of the most important thing about
controlling deer populations is make sure
in the population doesn't get too big for
the resources that they have available
to them.
You can't have a bunch of deer starving
to death and getting sick and diseases
because there's no food, you know,
and deer, we'll just like rabbits,
just like rats, just like any
other animal. That's wild.
And especially in a competitive
environment like that,
they breed as much as
they can. I mean the, the,
the pump out as many little baby
deer as possible. And I want, if you,
if you go to a place like where I
lived in Boulder, I lived in Colorado,
they don't, nobody in Boulder's all
nutty, crunchy and no one's shooting deer.
So the deer like fearless,
so they're everywhere.
So you have to be very careful
when you drive it around.
Could you get slammed into him at night?
They'll just jump in front of the road
and all of a sudden, you know, there's,
there's a fucking deer with his
antlers through your windshield,
goring you to death, you know? But
that happens to be Paul. It's tricky.
So if you're not eating cows and you're
nodding and Glam and you're nodding what
you're going to have to do something,
you have to separate them,
keep them from breeding. You ever to
do something to control the population,
you're going to have to
be proactive about it.
I mean that, I'm not against eating meat.
I think it's, I would, I don't like,
and what makes me cry
is when, yeah, exactly.
I watched a documentary called Food Inc,
which I literally have never so hard.
Yeah. You don't, you ever watch
Anthony Bourdain's show? No, I, no,
I haven't seen that actually. Good
show. It's called no reservations.
It's on the travel channel. He's a chef
and it was really interesting guys,
one of my favorite shows and he goes all
over the country and all over the world
even and uh,
goes to all these different cultures and
sees like what they eat and talk to the
people there and tries to find out
their traditions about their food.
Kind of really fascinating.
Well one of the things he did,
he went to this place in Maine and this,
this uh,
it's a restaurant in Maine that does
everything. They have their own farm,
they grow all their own produce,
they grow all their own animals.
They slaughter their own animals,
butcher their own animals and
then serve them and cook them.
And it was really interesting. Yeah.
Because here's these, these guys,
I mean this guy was petting this
peg and he's like, you know,
it's kind of weird cause you know your
pet net but then you're also like looking
at it like,
wow,
this is going to make some Nice Bacon
and there's some ham right here.
And like it's a real,
it's the reality of it and you know,
that's what they're there for.
They're not going to live forever
if you don't eat them. Okay.
They're eventually going to die.
These are temporary creatures and it's
like to give them as much freedom and
dignity and you know,
and to treat them as humanely
as possible before you kill him,
you're still killing them.
The real problem is that right?
The real problem is not the killing them.
The real problem is the suffered
suffering before he killed.
Horrible because this didn't seem
offensive. It seems shocking to me.
Like does this guy was petting this pig
talking about it being bacon and ham,
but you still petting the pig and the pig
like wasn't freaked out at all and the
pig was eating well. And it's like, okay,
well I mean that's the food chain. Yeah,
I guess.
But that's the problem with a lot of
the animal rights people and the animal
rights movement. It's like they
don't believe in the food chain.
They believe we stop killing
animals, period. But if we do that,
like you have to take into consideration
that a lot of animals are here and
they're here as prey animals.
Like in the natural cycle of things.
If you have deer,
well you have to have mountain lions.
If you don't have mountain lions take
out these deer or coyotes to take out
these deer, well we'll, who fucks gonna
eat all the deer w what are you going to,
you're going to have a just
gigantic overpopulation of them.
What are you gonna do?
You're going to start breeding mountain
lions and now you have mountain lions
everywhere. You have millions of outlines
and millions of deer. Like really?
Is that the solution? Well, something's
going to happen, right? I mean,
we look at this Utopian Granola fucking
Unicorn way of life that you know,
hey man, we should just leave the
animals alone. We're kind of past that.
We can't really do that. There's,
there has to be some sort of a,
if you were going to stop
eating animals through,
who would have to be some sort of strategy
for dealing with overpopulation and
right now we can't even control that
with animals like cats and dogs.
We have a hard time. We're killing
them and fucking, you know,
the rescue places are killing them
left, right Pete? It kills them.
Peta kills animals left at rice,
all the animals on boats, so
they stroke, they're still alive.
There's so much extra water out there
and you just let them float for the rest
of their life.
Holocaust of animals,
we keep killing animals and
keeping them in cells as sad.
So many chihuahuas that are fucking
murdered or put to sleep every year,
especially in California because people
just by Chihuahuas and then send them
back to the,
like if you go to the pounds,
they're shipping chihuahuas
out of California to other
states to try to get rid
of them because there's so much to over
Chihuahua population. You know, it's,
it's like instead of killing
all these swabs in Paris with, I'm on a
boat to go in Paris Hilton. Totally. Yeah.
I loved her in high school though.
I bought her, I bought her book,
her book between her and Judge Anderson,
who's been the bigger influence on your
life? Um, I wouldn't call them influences.
I would just call those pretty
girls that I'm interested in.
People that you're interested
in. Yeah. Oh my God.
I loved when their true Hollywood stories,
when we're on the Hilton sisters
and then, um, Jenna Jamison. Yeah.
There was another Hilton. Whatever
happened. That one, she kind of faded out.
Hilton, she's still around
and, but she puts up,
I used to follow her on Twitter and they
were so dumb that really disappointed
cat stacks. There's, I hate cats stacks.
That's her Twitter name and it's all
about her fucking all these rappers.
She fucks all these rappers and she gets
videos of her with these rappers and
then she's like, he'd be all doing
cocaine. Dick Holly get logged this.
They get Bailey,
fuck me and,
but she's got like a hundred
thousand fucking more than that.
Almost 200,000 Twitter
followers on Twitter. I have a,
I used to want to follow up points or
center where they do not stop tweeting.
They tweet,
go on and get my workout on every all day,
every day. Children looking to
connect with someone that loves them.
I like to follow, not the porn
stars. I like to follow them,
but then when I look at
them replying to a guy,
then I like to go to his website and
see what does that guy have to say?
These guys that are
tweeting the porn stars car.
That's where the fucking
real interesting shit is.
You know I went to this one guy and
it was like silence of the lambs.
It was like kicking in the door with the
flashlight flashlight with the fucking
pistol, like going, oh shit.
I went to this guy's Twitter page and it
was all him interacting with porn stars
and a lot of it was like crazy talk.
A lot of it was like,
you know,
you are incredibly inspirational to me.
I just think it's amazing how
you put yourself out there.
My God, I mean, I don't
know how you do it,
but it moves me and I feel
connected to you. And um,
since you've contacted me and this guy's
going on and on and on like 10 tweets
in a row, the same person, you know, when
you know you get nutty, it's like, dude,
you can't recognize the
concept of 140 characters. No,
it's 140 and 140 more than 140 more. And
like, I just stopped reading your shit.
Sorry, I can't read that. This guy
had like 10 10 to one porn star.
What's really weird is the people that,
you know,
all the porn starts have like their
shopping lists, their Amazon wishlist.
I did know about that until like
a year ago. How gross is that? Oh,
it's totally guys. Instead they
just pumped that shit all day.
There was somebody that said
something the other day,
I can't remember who it
was and I hopefully I'm not
friends with this person,
but they said something like, uh, Oh,
you guys getting mad at me for
pumping my Amazon wishlist.
I showed you my boobs
yesterday. Come on. Really?
I need to be paid for this. Right.
I need to be paid for my boobs.
Jesus Christ. Just give me the
PS three slim. I just want it.
How weird is that? The Amazon
wishlist? It's like, come on,
I know you're a loser by me. Some shit.
What's really weird is that I, I uh,
is how many people actually
buy them stuff? Oh,
that guy with the 10 fucking
tweets to the porn star.
He's definitely butter
their underwear stop.
Like when I used to know this
girl that did it, porn, uh, she,
she would get like shoes from the guy
and then like outfits and then like a
purse and then sunglasses. It was like
this guy felt like he was dating her. Oh,
you think about it like 10 years ago,
there was no way for a creepy guy on the
internet to contact a porn star and now
he has Twitter and connects. You look
at our response letters back and if he,
yeah, if he does something
cool like buys her a new purse,
you know for sure she's going to
say, Oh mg, thank you so much.
You're so sweet.
Yeah.
And then maybe she's going to come to
Cleveland and fucking show her pussy at
some club. You know, they do that.
They go on the road. All these things.
While a lot of these girls,
she's poor girls that you know
that the industry has fallen apart.
It used to be the porn industry.
You know,
they could just get into porn and they
could get a vivid contract and we a ton
of money while the Internet crushed it.
You know what I mean? There's free porn.
It's everywhere else buying porn.
It's like this.
The business has completely fallen apart.
The business model just eroded
because of the Internet.
So why the recession happened?
The Internet before, well,
they had a legitimate fucking beef.
You know,
they were talking about people
getting bailouts. They're like,
what about the porn
industry? Right? We're like,
we're going to bail you out like you
dirty birds. That's pretty fucked up too.
True.
It's a legit business where billions of
fucking dollars are coming from it and
millions and millions of people all
throughout this country are enjoying porn
and it's a legit,
it's a legit business to bail out,
but no one would ever dare spend your
fucking tax dollars keeping some fucking
porno house at Chatsworth or over, you
know? Yeah. It's crazy. Right? Totally.
What was really weird to me is I
don't get the whole, like I say,
like you like gin and Jamison and
you're just like, ah, you know,
you can't find any videos,
agenda.
Jamison on the Internet for some reason
the Internet is broken or whatever.
For Jenna Jamison videos, what? Right.
So you see there's a video of her that
costs $10 and it's just her getting anal
and then [inaudible] name.
Okay, well as an example, right?
They do with a way more than 10 bucks
is what I'm trying to say. Here's,
here's miscellaneous hot girl over here,
anal video for free. Why would you,
why is there that big of a difference
to pay 10 bucks to see this girl, Dude,
oh dude, guys become obsessed with a
girl, becomes their jerk-off girlfriend.
I use that, I guess, uh, porn it as
masturbation and then once I'm done,
I'm not watching porn. Something still
they fixate on one chick, they'll like,
they'll have this one girl,
you know, for whatever reason,
she just does it for them.
And they did decide.
They've jerked off a couple of times
to her and it was very satisfying.
So decided they're only gonna
go to her videos at one time.
This is really embarrassing. I'm my
space messaged a porn star that I liked,
but did you say I really like you?
If you're ever in La,
you should come to one of my shows
like a girl, Bree Olsen. Whoa.
Free Olsen. Black Dick.
Like a champ. She's so cool.
Like a duck to water.
She is so cute.
And then the guy that I was dating
saw the message and it wasn't really
embarrassing
like
walking through the casino
[inaudible] she was like,
what is this mind space mass?
It is checking your my space.
That's a symptom of a greater evil.
That guy was looking for
Bri Holsten God Dang them
bitches out to writers.
I would be offended. They
were looking at my master's.
Yeah. What's that? Oh, I ever,
I don't know. Have you ever had someone
pick up your phone and just like,
let me see who you're texting.
Get the fuck off that. Yeah,
you got to grow up. I did want to touch
people's phones. Can't talk to my phone.
Whoa. Nice. Woo. Bri, Bri Olson. Um,
no one takes a big black
dick in the ass with a smile.
She's so innocent looking. She's so
innocent looking and she sounds innocent.
She's very vocal coach.
She still,
she's got that giant black snake in her
anus and she's like, Oh fuck my ass.
And like, whoa. Do Isis. Taylor is, no,
she's the last month pet a pet
of the month. She's pretty hot.
Then you got through our videos
and she just had black Dicks,
like two black dicks in her ass and
stuff like that just ruins a girl
because I don't even want
to say the names, but uh,
is there a few poor girls that
have done those? A gangbang videos.
That's, that's the number one. Ruiner oh,
like when it's like 98 cops in
10 seconds or more than that.
There are hundreds now
they're up to the hundreds.
One girl just broke the record recently.
I think she went like 600 and
then her friend there were,
I believe they were on open Anthony, they
were talking about this and her friend,
she was talking about how her friend just
broke the anal record and she was mad
that her friend,
like,
I'm going to go get that record
to see these people are insane.
I actually don't necessarily blame
them as much as I blame the people
surrounding them that are like,
yeah, keep doing it. Well, you know,
yes and no because listen,
you're dealing,
you're dealing with a fairly
finished product and you know,
if it's a shit sandwich, it's a shit
sandwich. What are you gonna do?
You're gonna scrape the shit
out and put mayonnaise down,
lay some new fucking meet and we're
going gonna make it ham and falafel. No,
it's a shit sandwich. This
bitch is crazy. If she's,
if she's a blow these guys out of videos,
she's going to be blown
someone at a concert or she's
going to let somebody fuck
her in the middle of a bar while a bunch
of people watch she's nuts. You know,
you're,
you're not going to be able to fix her
unless you have a time machine where you
can go back in time and stop her
stepfather from fingering her.
You're not going to be able to fix,
or I film it and then go back in time
10 more minutes and then stop it.
I don't even know what you just said.
If Future Shit. Oh, okay. Yeah, I mean,
unless you, you, it's
all what we said earlier.
It's all about the way they're
raised. You know, all human beings,
that's our number one problem is that
we're not concentrating on schools.
We're not concentrating on,
on educating people about parenthood,
providing people with child support and
child, you know, childcare and you know,
making like positive environments
for children to grow up in.
And then of course people are angry
because they can't get what they want.
They're told the, you know,
the world's their oyster,
but meanwhile they're living in a world
of shit and they're in their projects
and just,
and they're having babies and no one
wants to give them money and they got no
money and he's got no fucking
happiness and shit. Shit, Shit.
Kid grows up angry, fucked up, begets
more angry, fucked up behavior.
And then it all comes from that.
It all, it seems so simple,
but yet there's no resources put
towards it whatsoever. No one is on TV.
There's no politician saying we have to
do a way better job of raising children.
We have to do a way more
responsible job of parenting.
We have to understand
what the actual role is.
It isn't just this is your kid
and you're the dad. No, no, no.
You are in charge and managing
the development of a new
human being and you can
make that life incredible positive.
Really.
Like you can set connections in that
child's mind that are very positive and
loving and friendly and make that person
an asset to any community that they're
in. Or you can create a monster.
Right? Yeah. It's a huge deal.
I mean it's amazing too how it's so
easy to become a parent and how he,
yeah, it's sad. It's so easy.
My accident by accident you have to go to,
yeah,
it should be hard as fuck to make pre
Paul people. It's just that again,
if it wasn't, I wouldn't
have made a person, you know,
I mean honestly my wife
got pregnant by accident,
but you might have like if
they made it like a college,
like he had to go through like four
years of like strange baby wouldn't have
done it, but maybe you would
them maybe it wouldn't have done.
It would be such a special thing that
you'd be like, I want it. I want a baby.
I get say that man. But you're
you, if you're, if you're selfish,
which I frick certainly was,
and you get used to your freedom and
you think about a buy a baby as an
infringement on freedom and like, I'll
do it someday. Maybe someday, maybe,
maybe when I'm ready.
Maybe when I got this in line,
maybe when I got that I didn't have a
kid til I was 40 but in all those things
before the baby's actually born,
either you don't really understand
what it really is until you have one.
And then when you have one,
all that selfishness, it's
like, no, no, no, no, no.
This is like a part of me.
Like this isn't like a new person
that I have to take care of. It is,
but it's a part of me. Like you, you,
you have this connection to that child
that really doesn't exist until you have
that connection. And you have to sort
of be incredibly ready for that. Yeah.
You gotta be ready and done everything
you want to do or you become ready as it
happens. You know, sometimes it
does. Ed. He's had a few friends,
girls that he dated that were just scan
aromas and all of a sudden they got
pregnant and they had kids and they
just changed everything. Went Veg,
started doing yoga. Stop fucking around,
no drinking, no drugs, clean sober,
going to meetings, you know, getting
their shit together, having a good job,
starting their own business because I
got a few stories of that because it's
just like the overwhelming responsibility
in love you feel for this kid.
I think it either clicks or it doesn't,
and you raise it porn,
star mushrooms and babies.
That's what it's all about folks.
Getting mushrooms to babies,
raising children the right way
and giving people mushrooms.
So we realize we're all connected.
This is my platform for 2012 I want to
run for president. We think not president.
I'm going to run for president
when president of the Internet.
I'm gonna Start my own thing. I think the
regular president thing is all rigged.
It's all bullshit. You know? It's
like, you know you're not in,
it's like campaigning to be
a character on a cartoon.
It's like the cartoons already
written like we don't need you.
We already have our players. We
already have, the roles are in,
no matter what your, it's a Democrat
or Republican or an or a cookie.
It's an independent, whatever it is, Green
party, libertarian or whatever he was.
No one's taking you seriously
stab a crat or it's Republican.
It's a fucking game.
It's a game that's already set up.
We need a new game president
of the Internet. Well
will it president Internet to kick out
all the cuts. Stop all the bullshit.
Make everybody nice.
I would set up the Internet at the
same way I set up my message board.
Why have one room, which is shit talking
one on one, which is like for everybody.
That's cool.
If you're nice and you're cool and
even if you're kind of slow or you're,
you know, whatever, as long
as you're not a Douche bag,
just go on there and post and try to
have a good time and try not to spam and
try to, you know, engage in
interesting conversations.
But if it become a douchebag,
we give you a pink name.
And we send you to the retard room and
you could still go to shit talking one oh
one but you can't post
anymore. It's pretty much like
how it is now though. You,
you either out of prison are in
prison or you get the electric chair
again, there's analogies. He's
motherfucker, they're there.
They don't make any sense.
This whole strange.
You're saying you would have your world
or your country be like your message
board where you're either in the
normal mess up or the country.
I'm talking about managing the Internet.
I'm talking about being president,
the Internet, right? Eventually we
will live in a world. You see, well,
we'll not be a regular world.
We're going to be connected, right?
And when that happens, I think we
should set it up like a message board.
Got to have a Douche bag
room, right? Which is prison.
But it's not because you don't
want to put someone in a cage.
Prison is for fucking real assholes.
You know
what? Prison, yes, he, terrible analogy.
But prisoner would prison really should
be for his people will hurt people.
Whether you steal from them with you
and when they bring you into prison,
you know, ideally it should
be all right, sit down.
We've got to figure out how to fix
your life. But that's not what it is.
It's like, here's a guy
who's going to rape. You
want me to keep me to join a white
gang? Because you're white. You know,
you need to get down with the Latinos
because you're Mexican. You know,
fuck how we know that that goes on and
there's nothing done about it. Well,
there's a website, stop prison, rape.com.
It's stories. Meanwhile, the stores,
that dude's beat off to Wellesley,
it's probably not even real stories.
It's probably just some sick fuck.
It was like a fan of prison rape.
Like some dudes are a fan of
civil war reenactments. Yeah.
He's faced like letters to home
from a civil civil war soldier.
This guy is faking it. No prison
rape stories. And on that note,
ladies and gentlemen, that's the end
of the podcast. We'd like to thank, um,
little Esther for coming.
We would like to thank, uh,
the fleshlight of course
for sponsoring our podcasts.
You can go to Joe rogan.net. My website
has a link and if you click on that link,
you go to the flashlight, you get
15% off. It's all fixed now, right?
Does that Brian [inaudible] a coupon
code that you just use? Rogan.
Now does it say it? Yeah, it says on the
banner, you click, it goes in and says,
okay, so there's a coupon
code. Uh, and that's,
that's good for 15% off.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this right now we're going
to play dream weaver. Folks,
this is a song from the 70s.
Yeah. Yet in 1969 maybe.
And um, if you're around this weekend
is UFC of course. Oh, that's right. Um,
Friday night,
tomorrow night I am in Santa Ana at the
Galaxy Theater with Joey Coco Diaz one
show 8:00 PM.
We're ready to throw the fuck down.
That's if Joey's not mad at me
for not answering the phone.
I called you twice cock sock
fucking podcast. Who gives a shit?
You don't even know those people.
I'm family. So that's tomorrow night,
which is a Friday,
October 22nd.
And we were at the galaxy theater. Um,
and if you're around on Monday night,
October 25th, our pal Don Barris has a
show in the main room, the Ding Dong show.
And uh, if you're a fan of freak shows,
if you're a fan of, of chaos and,
and odd human beings, Don Barris knows
how to put it together, like watching,
not craziness. And it's going to be a
huge event, like a big party. Seriously.
Shockingly unbelievable. It's so funny.
Yeah. And Don's a great guy and he's,
the problem is the new comedy store is
kind of not appreciating dawn's efforts.
So this, if this doesn't work, he
might be kind of forced out of their,
like Brody Stevens has been, last
time I was, I saw the Dingdong show,
there was a schizophrenia comic, I
forget his name and he said, yeah.
And he used to do open mic with him and
he took off all his pants and he only
was wearing, uh, a, uh, what's that
thing that you hate and you like thongs,
fanny pack. He was only wearing a
fanny pack, but his balls were so long,
his balls were hanging below the
fanny pack. That's odd sound.
It's, that's just to kind of show you
what craziness happens when you're, yeah.
You know, if you're on an asset,
it's definitely the show for you.
The guy that created the movie that
made the movie windy city heat,
which is unbelievably funny. Yeah.
Don Barrett's is a special character.
He's a real institution at
the comedy store. I mean,
I can't even think about the comic store.
I'll think about dawn Barris.
He's always been one of those guys has
done crazy late night sets there and he's
just a fun dude and awesome.
And he works for the Jimmy Kimmel show.
He warms up the crowds and he's always,
you know, doing sketches and stuff.
He's a great guy. Great Guy. And so
October 25th, if you're around a,
that's money at the comedy store in
the main room at 10:00 PM and um,
[inaudible] dot com all one word or
little underscore Esther at Twitter.
Little Esther is a e.
S t, h, e R. I, f. F,
f cranking. Man, what are you doing?
History, William. Mary me. This is
a great song, man. This is a great,
I'm driving home to an empty road.
You know what I'm saying?
I never heard this song.
If you're in the Midwest,
you have a tattoo of place where a place
where there's no streetlights and you
get to see all the fucking stars
when you're on a little shitty road,
two lanes each way.
Very few
scars [inaudible]
and if you've got a good stereo system
and you know somebody who's got good weed
and you drive it home and you hear this,
especially if it's on satellite radio
where it's nice and clear and you're like,
fuck yeah,
give me some volume on is
Brian play this the fuck out.
Whoever wrote this somewhere,
his wife's get struck by a personal
trainer and that's just a fact.
She wanted to take some MMA classes.
Dick UFC one 21 to Saturday
night on paper view.
That's it. That's all. All our plugs
you little asked you for coming by.
It was a lot of fun. Thank you Brian.
Thank you. Thank you everybody. We love
you bitches. We'll see you next week.
Come on.
Volume.
When it stopped.
That's rude.
Oh, you just cut it off. So, so sad.